bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne un débat sur les discriminations
c'est Bariza Kari sénatrice socialiste
de Paris qui est à l'initiative de ce
débat objectif dresser un bilan de la
politique du gouvernement en matière de
lutte contre les discriminations pour
Barry Zakari le bilan du gouvernement
est négatif car les principales mesures
en faveur de la lutte contre les
discriminations ne sont pas appliquées
par exemple le CV anonyme ou la
suppression des conditions de
nationalité française lié à certains
emplois ce débat intervient également
alors que le Sénat doit auditionner la
semaine prochaine Jeanette bourab la
candidate choisie par Nicolas Sarkozi
pour présider la Alde bonne matinée à
tous sur Public Sénat la parole est à
Madame barar auteur de la question pour
20 minutes
nous vous
écoutons monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre dans le
cadre de la Semaine de contrôle
parlementaire la question que porte le
groupe socialiste aujourd'hui a pour
objectif de faire un bilan d'étapes sur
la politique gouvernementale en matière
de lutte contre les
discriminations toute inégalité de
traitement fondé sur un critère
illégitime est une offense aux valeurs
qui porte notre République et notre
volonté de vivre ensemble liberté
méritocratie égalité des droits
solidarité nationale laïcité justice
respect de la dignité humaines ces
termes devraient être les balises de
l'action publique dans le combat que
nous devons mener contre les
discriminations ce combat est la
condition d'un pacte républicain vivant
dans les relations sociales
quotidiennement massivement impunément
voire même inconsciemment les pratiques
discriminatoires fragilisent ce pacte à
cet égard la responsabilité du du
gouvernement est de les dénoncer et de
les combattre le grand débat sur
l'identité nationale a-t-il permis de
contribuer à se vivre ensemble à
l'évidence non pendant plusieurs
semaines nous avons assisté médusé à un
concours de propos inqualifibl
lors de débats organisés par les
préfectures c'est-à-dire l'État lui-même
ce débat loin de promouvoir les valeurs
fondamental de la communauté nationale
les a piétiné loin de lutter contre les
tentations de REP repli identitaire les
a encouragé et nous n'avons même pas
dans l'opposition la satisfaction de
nous réjouir qu'il vous ait servi
électoralement qu'il vous a desservi
électoralement tant il a donné une
nouvelle vigueur médiatique aux préjugés
et aux stéréotypes racistes les
personnes issues de l'immigration qui
vivent sur le territoire de la
République qu'elles soi étrangère ou
française en sont les premières victimes
ce résultat est d'autant plus
condamnable qu'un apparent consensus
politique avait émergé ces dernières
années sur la nécessité de combattre les
pratiques et phénomènes discriminatoires
car monsieur le ministre ce sont en
premier lieu ces phénomènes aussi
répandus banalisés que corrosifs qui
alimente le repli identitaire tous les
acteurs sociaux en sont désormais
conscients à l'exception regrettable de
l'Exécutif beaucoup œuvrent
quotidiennement pour faire avancer ce
combat les initiatives tant au niveau de
certaines entreprises qu'à l'échelle de
toutes les collectivités locales se sont
multiplié Toulouse a lancé un
observatoire des discriminations Paris
et la Halde ont signé un partenariat
pour mener des actions d'information et
de sensibilisation l'îégalement le
Conseil régional d'Île-de-France a signé
une convention pour portant sur le
recrutement et la gestion des personnels
du conseil régional ainsi que la
création d'un observatoire des bonnes
pratiques le Parti socialiste a dans ses
engagements de campagne pour les
élections régionales adopt une charte
prévoyant la création de missions
régional de lutte contre les
discriminations chargée de mettre en
œuvre des engagements concrets le
président de la République lui-même ne
manque pas une occasion de rappeler
l'importance de la lutte contre les
discrimination son attachement à la
méritocratie et à à l'égalité des
chances mais à l'abri des grands
discours élyséens les pratiques
discriminatoires prospères dans
l'absence manifeste de volontarisme
politique le droit existant peine à être
appliqué et les décisions du législateur
ne sont pas suivies des faits 18
critères de discrimination sont prohibés
par le code
pénal ces critères sont de nature
différentes mais ils ont une racine
commune la méfiance à l'égard de ce qui
est perçu comme différent cette méfiance
pétrie de préjugés et de beaucoup
d'ignorance aboutit à reléguer sinon
exclure de la société des segments de
plus en plus importants cela a été dit
tout à l'heure dans le débat sur les 35
heur nos seniors qui grâce à un système
de soin encore performant vivent mieux
et plus longtemps mais sont évincés du
marché de l'emploi les femmes qui grâce
à un barême fiscal familial adapté et
des structures de la petite enfance sont
nombreuses sur le marché du travail mais
souffr d'une évolution de carrière moins
favorable que les hommes sans même
parler du niveau de leur salaire et
surtout tous ceux français ou non issus
de la dernière grande vague
d'immigration qui peine à trouver aussi
bien un travail qu'un logement l'enquête
trajectoire et origine publiée hier
menée par l'INET des Linc mesure les
discriminations en lien avec l'origine
ce fait déjà vérifié à l'occasion de
différents testings est à présent établi
par un cadre méthodologique rigoureux
riche en enseignement il en ressort
notamment qu'une personne issue
d'immigration titulaire d'un titulaire
d'un diplôme de l'enseignement supérieur
se sent plus discriminée qu'une personne
non diplômée on peut arguer avec raison
que l'instruction mène à une conscience
plus aigue des discriminations on peut
surtout en déduire que la République
peine à honorer sa promesse
méritocratique envers les filles et fils
d'immigrés français ou étrangers en
raison de leur origine et de la couleur
de leur peau cette injustice banalisée
quotidienne impunie ne constitue pas
seulement une blessure individuelle elle
constitue une offense à la méritocratie
républicaine dont sorgillé la France
aucune pratique discriminatoire n'est à
noodine parce qu'elle est une remise en
cause de la personne dans sa dignité ses
conséquences immédiates et de plus long
terme sont mortifaire aussi bien pour
l'individu que pour la société dans son
ensemble je dis souvent que les
discriminations aboutissent à des morts
sociales on dit à nos jeunes travaillez
faites des études c'est votre sésame or
un diplôme équivalent les jeunes issus
de l'immigration tout comme les
ultramarins ont beaucoup plus de
difficultés dans l'accès à l'emploi que
les autres sans même parler des
difficultés d'accès au logement le pacte
républicain est donc pour beaucoup un
miroir aux alouettes les processus
discriminatoires aboutissent à priver de
son sens la notion d'égalité
et à réduire le pacte républicain à une
coquille vide laissant place à des
demandes communautaires inacceptables
c'est pourquoi je considère la lutte
contre les discriminations comme un axe
d'action majeure au service de la
justice sociale et de la cohésion
nationale à ce jour le bilan du
gouvernement est négatif certes
plusieurs collègues de votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre sont
issu de l'immigration loin de moi l'idée
de contester la portée symbolique de
leur nomination je déplore que cette
diversité gouvernementale faceasse au
fice de solde de tout compte et servent
de paravant à des propos inadmissibles
et des calomnies de canniveau quand des
ministres les élus et les candidats de
la majorité persistent à faire
l'équation entre noir arabe et
délinquant multirécidiviste on est en
droit de s'interroger sur la
considération que vous portez au modèle
républicain la banalisation des
contrôles de police au fciè dénoncé
prudemment par la Commission nationale
des ontologies de la sécurité et
sévèrement par Amnesy internationale
participe de cette stigmation
généralisée et pire lui confère un
aspect quasi
institutionnel la polémique actuelle
autour des propos d'un pilier de barre
du PAF s'inscrit dans ce climat
délétaire dans ce climat délétaire où le
tir à vu sur les noir et les Arabes
devient une activité tolérée la
population immigrée ou issue de
l'immigration n'est pas plus et pas
moins délinquante que la population
issue du corps traditionnel français par
ailleurs les actes de délinquence ne
s'expliqu pas par le patrony ou le taux
de mélanine mais bien par des variables
sociales bien identifiées la seule
avancée notable de ces C dernières
années repose sur la création et
l'activité de la Haute autorité de lutte
contre les discriminations et j'ai le
devoir de vous rappeler que cette
innovation institutionnelle ne peut-être
porté au crédit de la majorité politique
la création de la Halde résulte en effet
d'une directive européenne annoncée dans
le traité d'Amsterdam de 1999 c'est
Martin au BRI alors ministre de l'emploi
et de la solidarité qui a mis en place
dès 2000 le groupe d'étude et de lutte
contre les discrimination le gelde
préfigurant la future Alde sous la prise
sous la présidence de Monsieur schwedzer
à qui je tiens à rendre un hommage
appuyé la Alde pourvu pourtant de moyens
budgétaires limités au regard de ses
missions est devenue une institution
connue de près de 40 % de nos
concitoyens elle est parvenue sur
certains dossiers à faire évoluer les
pratiques et la réglementation je pense
notamment à la carte famill nombreuses
désormais accessiblebl aux familles
étrangères ses avis même non suivi des
faits permettent aux acteurs sociaux de
s'interroger sur leur pratique et d'y
remédier la Alde en tant qu'autorité
indépendante spécialisé exerce aussi
bien son magistère et son action dans le
domaine public et privé elle est partie
prenante des procédures judiciaires
enfin elle exerce ses compétences selon
le principe de la collégialité sa
spécialisation et gage de compétences
d'efficacité et de reconnaissance on
entend dire que le Sénat à l'occasion de
l'examen de la loi organique fin mai
prochain serait fortement incité à
intégrer laal dans le giron du futur
Défenseur des droits pourquoi vouloir la
faire disparaître du paysage
institutionnel alors que le chantier de
la lutte contre les discriminations est
à peine commencé alors que les données
dont on dispose témoignent d'une
situation préoccupante créé en 2005 la
Alde a vu le nombre de saisies passer de
1500 pour sa première année d'activité à
plus de 10000 pour l'année 2009 en
menant avec conscience son travail
d'expertise sur les textes de loi et de
compatibilité de notre législation avec
les les traités internationaux la Hal
est au cœur des missions que nous lui
avons nous parlementaires confié je
pense qu'il est à cet égard injustifié
de lui reprocher de jouer son rôle la
Hal ne s'est pas mise au-dessus du
Parlement elle a tenu avec efficacité
son rôle d'expertise juridique et nous
sommes attachés à sa pérennité je ne
comprends pas que l'on puisse reprocher
à la Halde de tenir son rôle quand
nous-même législateur nous ne parvenons
pas à contrôler l'application de nos
votes nous avons ensemble mes chers
collègues de part et d'autrre de
l'hémicycle voter trois dispositifs de
lutte contre les discriminations le CV
anonyme la création d'un dispositif
d'aide au vieux travailleurs migrants et
la suppression des emplois liés à une
condition nationalité or aucun de ces
votes n'a été suivi des faits pourtant
je suis intimement convaincu que la
lutte contre les discriminations ne peut
se contonner à de grands discours
généreux et qu'il vaut mieux en la
matière des décisions limitées mais
concrètes et effectives je regrette le
temps et l'énergie perdue dans les
débats récurrents et les débats
d'évitement sur les statistiques
ethniques et les véléités de
discrimination positive nous devons
changer nos pratiques pas nos principes
nos principes sont bons la lutte contre
les discriminations doit s'appliquer à
faire de l'ingénierie sociale c'est
ainsi notamment que s'est exprimé la
volonté du législateur avec le CV
anonyme sa mise en place aurait permis
au moins à l'étape de la sélection des
candidatures de gommer les différences
tant raciales que sociales ne laissant
la place qu'à des données objectives
d'expérience de compéten et de formation
notre tradition de méritocratie
républicaine impose l'anonymat au
concours et examen écrit il faut
aujourd'hui étendre ce principe au CV
anonymat au moment de la sélection des
CV permettant au recruteurs d'intervenir
en toute objectivité sur les seuls
critères de qualification suivi bien
entendu d'un entretien avec le candidat
lui permettant alors de faire valoir sa
personnalité cet outil aurait une portée
pédagogique évidente et permettrait de
lutter contre le conformisme des
recruteurs et l'autocensure des
candidats à l'emploi évidemment la lutte
contre les discrimination ne saurait se
réduire la promotion du CV anonyme je
n'ai pas la naïveté de croire qu'il
s'agirait d'une panacée il ne s'agit que
d'un outil parmi d'autres après son
adoption dans le casadre de la loi pour
l'égalité des chances le gouvernement a
renoncé à adopter le décret application
j'avoue qu'à cet égard j'ai été très
surprise d'entendre en janvier dernier
face à un panel de Français réunis à
l'occasion d'une émission de télévision
le président de la République se
flattait d'avoir fait adopter ce
dispositif première question monsieur le
ministre dans le cadre de ce contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement pourquoi cette
disposition législative pourtant
revendiquée face aux Français par le
président n'est-elle toujours pas
appliquée la deuxième mesure V des
parlements est toujours non appliquée
concerne les vieux travailleurs migrants
venus pour la plupart du Maghreb pour
travailler en France dans les années 60
70 ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
chibanis avaient l'intention de pouvoir
retourner dans leur pays une fois leur
labeur terminé ces vieux chibanis sont
seuls pauvres souvent analphabète leur
quotidien tourne autour du foyer
Sonacotra de parties de Domino et des
maigres sommes qu'ils envoient à leur
familles resté au pays et qui à leurs
yeux représentent la légitimité même de
leur existence aujourd'hui ils sont de
facto assigner à résidence en effet
après avoir connu une vie
professionnelle ponctuée par les
contrats courts suivant non souvent non
déclaré et mal rémunéré dans le bâtiment
et l'agriculture ils ne peuvent
prétendre aujourd'hui à une retraite
décente ils perçoivent en moyenne 150 €
de retraite contributive à ce ce revenu
s'ajoute le minimum vieillesse soit au
total 620 € mensuels mais pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce minimum vieillesse il
faut résider en France de façon stable
et régulière ils sont face à un
véritable dilemme rester en France pour
pouvoir envoyer un petit pécule à la
famille rester au pays ou bien rentrer
avec comme seule ressource leur
minuscule retraite aussi font-ils le
plus souvent le choix de rester en
France dans des conditions d'extrême
précarité et d'extrême solitude à
l'occasion de la discussion du projet de
loi relatif au logement opposable le
Sénat en plein accord avec monsieur
borlot a voté en faveur de la de a voté
en faveur de la création d'un dispositif
tout à fait innovant permettant à cette
catégorie de retraités pauvres de
pouvoir retourner chez eux pour des
périodes longues tout en préservant
leurs ressources et leurs droits la
portée effective mais aussi symbolique
de cette aide était forte symbolique
parce que ce vote intervenait 2 ans
après l'adoption de l'article sur
l'aspect positif de la colonisation
après l'effet déplorable de cette
formule sur les populations issues de
l'immigration des anciennes colonies il
était temps que la République F terre
ses atavismes coloniaux le nouveau
dispositif aurait pu y contribuer en
reconnaissant que ces immigrés issus des
anciennes colonies qui ont contribué à
la reconstruction de la France et à sa
croissance économique ont droit comme
tout individu à une retraite décente
l'unanimité autour de cette question est
à l'honneur du Sénat apporter une
réponse à la situation inacceptable des
chibanis était une question de dignité
dignité pour eux mais aussi dignité pour
la République Dee question monsieur le
ministre en dépit de ce vote unanime le
gouvernement n'a pas adopté le décret
d'application pourquoi la deème la 3è
disposition votée par le Sénat
concernait les emplois fermés cette
expression désigne les professions
libéral et privé dont l'exercice est
soumis à la double condition de diplôme
et de nationalité 600000 emplois sont
concernés il s'agit d'une législation
obsolète conotée et moralement
condamnable à formation et diplôme
identique le ressortissant extra
commomunautaire ne dispose pas des mêmes
droits que le ressortissant européen la
proposition de loi que j'ai porté visait
à supprimer la condition de nationalité
elle a été votée à l'unanimité des
groupes politiques au Sénat en février
2009 mais n'a pas encore fait l'objet
d'un examen à l'Assemblée nationale il
faut néanmoins noter que le gouvernement
a intégré une partie de la PPL dans le
texte Hôpital patients santé territoire
ainsi depuis 2000 depuis août 2009 les
médecins et personnels de santé dont les
métiers étaient visés par la clause de
nationalité peuvent désormais bénéficier
d'un statut identique à celui de leur
collègues français à condition monsieur
le ministre d'obtenir les engagements en
matière de changement de situation
administratif des diplômés concernés
enfin je je ne peux pas ne pas faire le
lien entre la CRI criminalisation de
l'immigration que vous mettez en place
de façon systématique et les
discriminations dont souffrent nos
concitoyens en ce moment même le Conseil
des ministres examine une nouvelle loi
durcissant l'entrée et le séjour des
étrangers c'est la 6e fois depuis 2002
et cette fois encore l'étranger
uniquement parce que étranger est traité
comme un criminel cela devient du
harcèlement législatif enfin Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai cru comprendre que le
gouvernement souhaitit pour resserrer
les liens de votre majorité revenir à
ces fondamentaux en faisant adopter au
plus vite une loi
antiburkaa il est important de rappeler
que cet accoutrement n'est pas une
prescription coranique la burka ne peut
donc être qualifié de voile intégral
islamique comme le titre est encore un
grand journal du soir cette
qualification erronné de plus en plus
répandu contribue là encore à
stigmatiser une confession et toute une
partie de la population française les
socialistes condamnent avec fermeté le
port du voile intégral qu'il jugent bien
évidemment incompatible avec les valeurs
de la République nous pensons également
que la burka peut-être de nature à
troublé l'ordre public mais en la
matière il nous semble nécessaire de
privilégier des voie l'action publique
pour lutter contre cette pratique
sectaire pédagogie et non démagogie
aussi nous nous opposerons à une loi de
circonstances pouvant conduire à des
dispositifs juridiquement contestables
inadaptés ou inapplicables j'appelle
votre attention sur le fait que
l'intégration ne passera pas par une
nouvelle stigmatisation d'une population
qui au quotidien souffre déjà de racisme
et de discrimination la France qu'on
aime est celle d'une une république
formée de citoyens égaux sans
distinction d'origine de sexes ou de
religion comme l'énonce notre
Constitution la France qu'on aime et
celle qui pendant des décennies est
parvenu à relever le défi politique qui
constitue à sublimer les identités
particulières pour forger une identité
collective puissante tournée vers
l'émancipation l'égalité la méritocratie
et un avenir bien évidemment à
construire ensemble les déclarations les
décisions mais aussi les non décisions
de votre gouvernement fragilise jour
après jour cette France-là et dessine
une société fracturée marquée par
l'inégalité l'injustice et l'exclusion
face à cette démission républicaine de
la majorité politique les socialistes
resteront mobilisés par des mesures
simple les parlementaires de tout bord
ont voulu s'attaquer aux pratiques
discriminatoir discriminatoire par notre
vote nous avons adressé un message
d'espoir aux populations fragilisées
alors pourquoi ces trois votes n'ont pas
été suivis des faits monsieur le
ministre
pourquoi
merci merci ma cher
collègue dans le débat la parole est à
ellian assassassi pour le groupe CRC SPG
ma cher
collègue nous vous
écoutons monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues une discussion sur la lutte
contre les discriminations est la
bienvenue au sein de notre hémicycle
même si malheureusement il faudrait bien
plus qu'une heure et demie de débat et
un auditoire bien plus large pour tenter
de réparer les dégâts causés par les
politiques de discrimination mené par ce
gouvernement et les clichés xénophobes
véhiculés faut-il le rappeler ici y
compris par certains de ces ministres
quelle soit
avOcatiOn électoraliste ou l'expression
d'un racisme ordinaire ces phrases
prononcées ont de quoi donner le vertige
mais ce n'était ce n'est peut-être pas
là le plus grave car si les paroles
s'envolent les écrits restent en effet
ces dernières années malgré une campagne
de communication
tonitruante les politiques publiques
menées par le Président de la République
et son gouvernement n'ont fait
qu'accentuer les discriminations qu'elle
soit raciale sociale d'accès au d'accès
au soins générationnel ou lié au sexe le
discours prononcé par le président de la
République le 17 décembre 2008 à l'École
polytechnique est à ce titre
particulièrement éloquent celui-ci
passait en effet en revue les différents
espaces sous s VI les discriminations et
pour son indigner et ainsi Monsieur
Sarkozi se demandait si je le cite l'on
pouvait encore parler de la de
République quand les l'école ne parvient
plus à compenser les handicaps sociaux
fin de citation questionnement assez
paradoxal quand on sait que ce
gouvernement est celui qui a supprimé le
plus de postes de professeurs en effet
en 2008 plus de 11000 postes de
professeurs ont été supprimés 13000 en
2009 et 16000 suppressions sont prévues
pour 2010 tout ceci au détriment des
établissements situés dans les quartiers
les plus défavorisés et des filières
professionnelles qui comptabilisent le
plus grand nombre de
suppression face à cette pénurie
dramatique les internats d'excellence
présentés comme le dispositif far du
volet éducation de la dynamique Espoir
banlieu font pâle figure passons outre
regardons les résultats monsieur le
Président yest regardons les résultats
je pense qu'on n pas la même lecture de
ces résultats passons outre le débat sur
le choix de discrimination positive
plutôt que l'augmentation des moyens
pour tous et attachons-nous justement au
résultat pour l'instant 120 élèves de la
4e jusqu'à la seconde sont concernés par
ce dispositif il est prévu qu'il soit
500 à l'horizon 2011 en somme pour un
élève placé en interlat d'excellence des
centaines de postes sont supprimés au
détriment de milliers d'élèves alors
dans ce même discours le président de la
République posait la question suivante
je le cite comment faire aimer la
République à ceux qu'elle tient à
l'écart à ceux qui ont la conviction que
quoi qu'il fassent les sacrific les
sacrif les sacrifices qu'il consentent
ils ne peuvent pas réussir fin de
citation au regard de l'abstention plus
que massive dans les quartiers
populaires notamment chez les jeunes la
question paraît en effet plus que
légitime dernièrement le rapport de
l'Observatoire national des zones
urbaines sensibles a montré que les
quartiers de la politique de la ville
s'étaient encore dégradés depuis les
émeut de 2005 en ZUS le chômage est plus
fort que partout ailleurs sur le
territoire et le CRE l'écart se creuse
toujours plus à caractéristiqu de
diplôme de sexe d'origine du père et de
nationalité identique un jeune habitant
de ZUS a a encore environ 1 1,3 fois
moins de chance d'obtenir un emploi
stable qu'un habitant d'autres quartiers
à cela s'ajoutent des problèmes urbains
majeurs un enclavement très fort un
déficit d'équipement et de présence de
l'État si la crise économique ser à
Libye pour expliquer cette situation
nous pensons pour notre part que
l'absence de politique publique et le
désengagement de l'État à travers la
suppression des services publics de
proximité sont les véritables
responsables de ce déclin à ce titre
l'exemple des inégalités face à la santé
est lui aussi particulièrement criant
l'accès aux soins est en effet de moins
en moins garantie la Réforme
hospitalière va produire à terme des
inégalités territoriales majeures de
plus les franchises médicales présentées
comme indolor ferme la porte d'accès à
la santé pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens c'est ce qu'affirme le
Conseil d'État dans un arrêté du 6 mai
2009 annulant en partie le décret de
2007 au motif que le montant des
franchises est de nature je cite à
compromettre le droit à la santé quant à
la loi sur la le handicap malgré des
promesses électorales elle a été un elle
a été peu à peu vidée de son sens à coup
de report des contributions financières
des entreprises de dérogation au règles
d'accessibilité de remise en cause des
compensation de retrait de l'État de la
prise en charge éducative et de la
régression de la laallocation
adultes handicapés et face à ce terrible
constat l'Association des Paralysés de
France a déclaré l'année 2009 année
noire du handicap et n'hésite pas à
parler de régression sociale majeure
enfin dans ce discours le président
s'interrogait sur je le cite encore
comment faire comprendre la République à
l'enfant qui se sent prisonnier de son
milieu de son quartier de ses origines
fin de citation j'oseraai dire
certainement pas
endurcissant toujours plus les
conditions d'accès à une situation
légale de résidence la politique
délirante d'expulsion menée par ce
gouvernement a produit les pires
résultats en terme de discrimination des
parents retirés à leurs enfants des
jeunes adultes expulsés dans des pays
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas des femmes
raccompagnées vers leur pays qu'elles
avaient fui pour pouvoir vivre libre des
personnes renvoyées dans des pays en
guerre j'arrête là la liste qui pourrait
être encore longue et pour ceux qui ont
échappé au labyrinthe bureaucratique de
l'obtention de permis de séjourou de la
nationalité française ils continuent à
subir les stigmates de leurs origines
une enquête menée en 2008 par l'INC et
l'INED montrit que 40 % des personnes
ayant déclaré une discrimination sont
immigrés ou enfants d'immigrés alors
qu'il ne représente que 22 % de la
population adulte résid en France une
étude tout aussi récente menée par deux
chercheurs du CNRS montre qu'en fonction
de la couleur de sa peau les choses les
chances de subir un contrôle d'identité
inopiné par les services de police
variaent de 1 à 7 face à cela les
confusions entretenues par les
gouvernements entre immigration identité
nationale religion et délinquence ne
font que banaliser toujours plus ces
discriminations au premier au premier
plan bien évidemment la création d'un
ministère de l'Immigration de
l'Intégration et de l'identité nationale
contribue à à entretenir cet amalgame
comme le disait à juste titre monsieur
Dien rapporteur général spécial de l'ONU
contre le racisme entendu en juin 2007
par le Conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'ONU ce ministère contribue je le cite
à une banalisation du racisme et une
lecture une lecture ethnique et raciale
des questions politiques économique et
social et le traitement idéologique et
politique de l'immigration comme un
enjeu sécuritaire et comme une menace à
l'identité
nationale face à cette multiplication
des discriminations auxquelles j'aurais
pu rajouter celle existence existante
dans le monde du travail notamment
s'agissant de l'égalité professionnelle
et salariale entre hommes et
femmes je vous pose une question quels
ont été les outils mis en place par le
gouvernement les internats d'excellence
comme nous venons de le voir il ne
concerernne qu'une grosse centaine
d'élèves la présence de 25 % d'élèves
boursiers dans les classes préparatoires
cette mesure n'est restée qu'à l'état de
déclaration l'augmentation de 25 % de
l'AH à l'horizon 2012 cela ne permettra
même pas d'atteindre le seuil de
pauvreté de pauvreté la mise en place du
Plan Espoir Bonlieu je vais être gentil
là mais de la vie de tous ce programme
est une coquille vide et un échec
total des autorités indépendante chargé
de défendre les droits des citoyens la
suppression de la Commission nationale
de déontologie de la sécurité celle du
Défenseur des enfants décidé
arbitrairement et sans aucune
concertation et comme nous le craignons
celle de la Halde dont les compétences
sont largement reconnu au profit d'un
défenseur des droits aux prérogatives au
aussi large que flou laisse augurer le
pire depuis 3 ans la lutte contre les
discriminations a fait l'objet de
nombreux débats de plan de
communication de rapport comme
d'ailleurs celui de Monsieur Sabeg qui a
sans doute été classé à la verticale de
déclarations fracassantes mais pour quel
résultat les dispositifs mis en place
n'ont eu qu'un effet marginal voire
aucun effet et les politiques de casse
sociale et de démantellement des
services publics menés par le
gouvernement n'ont fait que multiplier
les cas de discrimination et donc en
matière de lutte contre les
discriminations monsieur le ministre je
mets un Z0 poiné à votre
gouvernement merci ma cher collègue la
parole est à la présidente mugette Dini
pour le groupe Union
centriste la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne
reviendrai pas sur les points évoqués
par notre collègue Barry zakiari je
partage en grande partie son point de
vue si le gouvernement veut être
crédible dans la lutte contre les
disiscriminations il doit passer des
paroles aux actes et prendre les mesures
réglementaires attendues depuis trop
longtemps voilà presque 4 ans par
exemple que le CV anonyme a été
introduit dans la loi à l'initiative du
président Nicolas Abou si tout le monde
comprend que que la mise en place de
cette initiative demande un peu de temps
en raison de son caractère novateur
personne ne peut croire en revanche
après 4 ans de réflexion et de
négociation sans résultat que seule la
complexité explique cet échec monsieur
le ministre si le gouvernement veut
convaincre il lui faut montrer plus de
volonté et de détermination ce dont il
n'a pas manquer sur d'autres sujets
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaiterai que nous profitions de ce
débat pour nous interroger sur
l'évolution de la langue et des mots que
nous utilisons lorsque nous abordons ce
problème de
discrimination en réalité quand nous
évoquons ce sujet nous ne faisons que
nous pencher sur l'un des plus vieux
problèmes des sociétés humaines
l'injustice et l'inégalité les esclaves
Romains parlent d'affranchissement les
révolutionnaires français exigeaent
l'égalité des droits nous nous parlons
de discrimination mais il s'agit du même
sujet pourquoi que s'est-il passé
surtout quel présupposé et quel
conception de la société véhicule
souterrainement ce nouveau
vocabulaire la Révolution française nous
a légué une lourde promesse celle de
pouvoir grâce à la politique abolir
l'injustice et les inégalités sociales
jusqu'à une période récente ce combat
pour l'égalité était un combat collec
pé par l'idée de progrès nous allions
vers une société plus juste et plus
équitable depuis les années
1970 cette confiance en l'avenir s'est
fissurée les inégalités et le sentiment
d'injustice progresse de nouveau la
promesse n'est pas tenue qui est
responsable de ce recul c'est ici je
crois qu'intervient le basculement dans
le vocabulaire de la discrimination qui
est exactement contemporain du
creusement de la faille dans l'idée de
progrès quels sont les présupposés en
effet d'une analyse des injustices
sociales en terme de
discrimination parler de discrimination
c'est parler d'une volonté de traiter
différemment de traiter moins bien
d'exclure ce que présuppose ce
vocabulaire de la discrimination c'est
donc qu'au fond s'il y a des injustices
c'est la responsabilité de ceux qui
maltraitent ou qui excluent c'est ici
que l'on perçoit le danger politique et
l'erreur intellectuelle qu'il y a à
penser les inégalités en terme de
discrimination ce vieux problème des
injustices qu'aucune société humaine n'a
réellement réussi à résoudre nous
considérons nous qu'il est dû à
certaines personnes qui discriminent
c'est-à-dire qui maltraitent et exclu
quelle régression le combat pour
l'égalité hérité des lumières reposait
sur l'idée d'un projet collectif sur un
espoir d'amélioration commune qui
portait l'ensemble de la société le
vocabulaire de la lutte contre les
discrimination au contraire renvoie
chaque individus à ses origines et
généralise la suspicion envers les
autres il fait l'impasse sur les aspects
collectifs pour tout ramener à
l'individu il réduit les problèmes
généraux à des problèmes de personne je
vais prendre l'exemple de l'accès au
logement différentes enquêtes ont montré
qu'il est plus difficile pour une
personne dont le nom a une connaissance
a une consonance étrangère et à un
niveau de ressource égal de devenir
locataire c'est donc la preuve de
discrimination dans l'accès au logement
ceci étant quel est le véritable
problème en matière de logement c'est
évidemment le fait que le nombre global
de logement est insuffisant que la
demande est plus forte que l'offre on
voit bien donc le caractère à la fois
limité et presque nuisible de l'approche
du problème du L
en terme de lutte contre les
discriminations le combat pour l'égalité
d'accès au logement conduit à insister
sur le vrai problème c'est-à-dire le
manque global de logement alors que la
lutte contre les discriminations laisse
penser que si certaines personnes n'ont
pas de logement c'est parce que d'autres
ne veulent pas le leur louer d'un côté
donc on insiste sur les problèmes
collectif on incite chacun à prendre
part à la résolution des difficultés de
de l'ensemble de la société de l'autre
on appuie sur ce qui divise on simplifie
à outrance des problèmes collectifs pour
des réduire les réduire à des cas
personnels je prendrai un second
exemple le droit européen ne comporte
pas de principe général à travail égal
salaire égal valable pour tous mais il
énumère les motifs pour lesquels
l'employeur n'a pas le droit de traiter
moins bien un salarié parmi ces motifs
on trouve l'origine la race le sexe ou
bien encore l'orientation sexuelle on
voit bien dans ce cas que le droit pensé
en terme de lutte contre le
discrimination et non le combat pour
l'égalité entraîne le repli sur soi dans
une posture
victimaire pour protester contre une
inégalité salariale un employer ne
pourra pas faire valoir un principe
général valable pour tous mais devra
montrer que l'employeur a voulu
délibérément le traiter différemment en
raison de ses origines ou de son
orientation sexuelle comment peut-on
maintenir la cohésion sociale dans notre
pays si le droit même cantonne les
citoyens à leurs origines et les incite
à se diviser dans ce domaine monsieur le
ministre il est vital que le
gouvernement réagisse à Bruxelles pour
mettre fin à la propagation d'un droit
communautariste européen dans notre
législation nationale voilà maintenant 2
ans que la commission des affaires
sociales a adopté à l'unanimité une
résolution demandant au gouvernement de
modifier la 6e directive
antidiscrimination en cours de
négociation on sait que les
représentants de la France à Bruxelles
n'ont tenu aucun compte de cette
résolution la directive qu'elle vise est
pourtant dangereuse et la France
gagnerait à rejoindre l'Allemagne dans
son opposition ferme à ce texte voilà
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
quelques remarques que je souhaitais
vous soumettre si je devais les résumer
je dirais ceci soyons fidèles à
l'héritage des lumières efforçons-nous
de bâtir une société plus juste en
rassemblant les citoyens privilégions
donc le combat pour l'égalité à la lutte
contre les discriminations je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente alors il y a
une permutation parmi les orateurs du
groupe socialiste et je vais donc passer
la parole à Charles
Gautier monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues la question de notre votre
excellente collègue barisa riari sur les
dispositifs de lutte contre les
discriminations me permet de revenir sur
un sujet sur lequel notre Assemblée a
travaillé il y a quelques mois et qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur
parisariari et les membres du groupe
socialiste avaient déposé en janvier
2009 une proposition de loi visant à
supprimer les conditions de
nationalité qui restreignent l'accès des
travailleurs étrangers à l'exercice de
certaines professions libérales ou
privées il s'agissait de supprimer la
condition de nationalité pour l'exercice
de 10 professions réglementé pour
lesquels cette condition ne se
justifiait plus ou pas et qui entraîaiit
des discriminations particulièrement
injustifié à l'égard des ressortissants
extracommunautaires qui pourtant
remplissait toutes les conditions de
diplôme
requises la commission des lois m'avait
désigné rapporteur de ce texte j'ai donc
entendu les représentants de l'ensemble
de ces professions pour vérifier ce qui
pouvait justifier une telle situation et
de maintenir une condition de
nationalité en conclusion sur ces 10
professions
concernées la profession d'avocat pour
cause
de forte concurrence internationale et
celle de guide interprète ont été retiré
de la proposition de loi sur les h
professions
restantes les dispositions de la
proposition de loi concernant les
médecins chirurgiens dentiste
sache-femme et pharmacien ont été
reprises par la loi Hôpital Patient
Santé territoire définitivement adopté
en juillet 2009
il restait quatre
professions quatre professions pour
lesquelles les
discriminations lié à la nationalité
persiste aujourd'hui il s'agit des
architectes des vétérinaires des
géomètrre experts et des experts
comptables je vous rappelle qu'il s'agit
de personnes qui ont un diplôme
français et qui sont tout à fait
intégrés à notre communauté et qui
maîtrisent parfaitement la langue et
qu'ils sont tous en situation régulière
voilà toutes ces conditions étaient
remplies pourtant cette condition de
nationalité subsiste et les empêche
d'exercer le métier pour lequel ils ont
été formés et très souvent chez
nous la condition de nationalité peut
être justifiée lorsqu'il s'agit
d'officier public ou ou
ministériel mais ici pour les
professions précitées
il ne s'agit en général que de
restrictions historiquement datées elles
sont apparues en effet pour la plupart
au début du 19e siècle ou entre les deux
guerres mondiales dans des contextes de
crise ou de tension internationale
elles sont donc aujourd'hui parfaitement
injustifiées et
discriminatoires les situations qu'elles
engendrent sont d'autant plus
discriminant atire qu'elles sont parfois
détournées nous sommes là en pleine
hypocrisie par le biais de la
sous-traitance
ou de postes contractuel dans la
fonction publique finalement un certain
nombre travaillent leur profession mais
dans des conditions extrêmement
différentes donc l'état contourne ses
propres règles pour les professions
libérales des procédures d'exception
longues et stigmatisantes sont parfois
possibles
comment expliquer des exigences
supplémentaires pour ces professions par
exemple prenons le cas des
architecte un architecte dans un
concours international peut gagner les
plus beaux concours proposés par la
France et cela a existé
oui c'est ça il peut gagner le concours
mais il peut pas ouvrir un
cabinet il va lui falloir alors trouver
un cabinet porteur
se faire embaucher et travailler sur son
propre
projet comment expliquer la même chose
vis-à-vis donz des
vétérinaires je vous ai expliqué que
pour le corps médical c'est à peu près
réglé cela veut donc dire que nous avons
plus
d'exigence pour faire soigner nos chats
nos chiens ou nos
vaches que pour faire soigner nos
enfants répondit à cette
question notre Haute Assemblée avait sur
ces bases là et contenu de son bon
sens adopté la proposition de loi de
notre ami
barisariari ainsi modifié par la
commission des lois et je vous rappelle
c'est assez rare pour que ce soit
signalé
avait été voté à
l'unanimité et bien
elle n'a
malheureusement jamais été mise à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
une partie de la proposition de loi
ayant été satisfaite par la loi
hospitalière dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure le chemin à parcourir pour Bâ
pour banir cette dernière discrimination
reste donc court encore faut-il que
votre majorité monsieur le ministre s'en
donne les moyens en tant que rapporteur
de cette proposition de loi je m'associe
donc évidemment aux demandes insistantes
de notre collègue
barisariari pour que le gouvernement
règle rapidement le sort de ces quatre
dernières professions je vous remercie
de votre
attention merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à notre collègue Françoise
Laborde pour le groupe
RDSE
nous vous
écoutons monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues l'histoire de notre pays est
ainsi faite que les vagues successives
de migration sans remonter en des temps
immémoriaux ont enrichi chacune à le
leur tour le corps de la nation les
récents chiffres publiés par l'Office
des migration internationale de l'ONU
montre d'ailleurs que la France est la
deuxième terre d'accueil de migrants
dans le monde
notre pays fort de son idéal de patrie
des droits de l'homme peut
s'enorgueillir d'une tradition longue
d'accueil des étrangers tradition dont
on trouve déjà la trace dans
l'introduction du droit du sol par
l'article 3 du titre 2 de la
Constitution de
1791 l'enracinement républicain de ce
droit en
1889 fut certes motivé par l'idée de
fournir davantage d'hommes aux armées
dans l'obsession d'une revanche face à
l'Allemagne les soubressau de l'histoire
du monde ontincidé avec les vagues
successives
d'immigration systématiquement
l'étranger fut pointé du doigt exclu
assigné dans un rôle de bouc émissaire
responsable de tous les mots avant
d'être finalement et heureusement
accepté cela n'a évidemment pas changé
aujourd'hui en revanche ce qui a changé
c'est l'urgence de définir un véritable
modèle d'intégration pour ses étrangers
et surtout pour leurs enfants tous
français à
partentière notre pays est aujourd'hui
divers dans son corps social mais encore
monoliique pour ce qui relève des
leviers de pouvoir qu'il soi politique
ou économique cela aussi doit changer
quel espoir la République peut-elle
offrir aux filles et fils d'immigrés
lorsqu'ils subissent dans leur vie
quotidienne la lèpre des
discriminations comment ne pas
s'inquiéter des chiffres alarmants de
l'abstention dans certains quartiers
populaires aux élections région
preuve s'il en fallait encore une du
rejet d'une partie de nos compatriotes
du modèle de société qui leur est
offert comment ne pas être consterné
lorsque votre gouvernement monsieur le
ministre nous impose une réforme des
collectivités territorial qui
s'affranchit sans scrupule du principe
de parité entre hommes et femmes
l'égalité des citoyens proclamée à
l'article 1er de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen du 26
août 1789 n'est n'est encore qu'une
chimère les discriminations sont bien
sûr multiples et au plus visibles
s'ajoutent les plus insidieuses tout
aussi aliénante sexe origine ethnique
origine sociale handicap orientation
sexuelle ou opinion politique le combat
pour l'abolition de ces discriminations
a malheureusement un bel avenir les
délis de fascièe ou de patronyme sont
d'une consternante banalité laalde a
d'ailleurs connu en 2009 une hausse de
21 % des
requêtes la République ne doit pourtant
laisser personne sur le bord du chemin
dans son discours de l'École
polytechnique du 17 décembre 2008 le
président de la République souhaitait
prendre à bas bras le corps le problème
des discrimination avec le volontarisme
d'intention qu'on lui connaît les
annonces semblaient aller dans la bonne
direction diversification de la
composition des classes préparatoires
aux grandes écoles création d'internat
d'excellen
généralisation du CV anonyme création
d'un label Diversité pour les
administrations et les entreprises
diversification des nominations au
postees de haut fonctionnaire hélas et
malheureusement sans surprise ces
annonces n'ont pas été suivis des faits
ni de mesures concrètes laissant nos
compatriotes discriminés dans leur juste
colère depuis 2002 et malgré les divers
textes législatifs planans de lutte ou
autres mesures annoncé la ségrégation
sociale n'a pas reculé d'un yota la
nomination médiatisée de personnalités
issue de la diversité à de haut postes
cache avec grande difficulté la
multiplication des zones reléguées au
marge de la
République je prendrai un autre exemple
celui de la rénovation baclé des grands
ensembles urbains elle a produit une
forme de ségrégation elle-même source de
davantage d'exclus du pacte républi
ce sera au cœur de mes préoccupations
lors de la discussion du projet de loi
Grand Paris au Sénat la semaine
prochaine tous ces plans de lutte contre
les discriminations ont englouti des
dizaines de millions d'euros pour des
résultats peu probants l'égalité des
chances peut demeurer qu'un beau slogan
si elle n'est pas réellement favorisée
soyons clair l'égalité des chances n'est
pas l'égalité absolue l'école creusée de
la diversité sociale par excellence doit
jouer le rôle de vecteur d'ascension
sociale elle n'y parvient plus en dépit
du dévouement et de l'engagement des
enseignants force de constater que
l'école n'est aujourd'hui plus en mesure
de donner à chaque élève quel que soit
son milieu ou son origine les même
chance d'épanouissement et de mobilité
sociale sur ce point le recrutement des
élèves des grandes écoles demeur d'une
rare andogamie pire et ce chiffre est
particulièrement éloquent la part des
élèves de l'enat issus de milieu
populaire a reculé pour stagner autour
de 12 % entre 1980 et aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes sont équeœurés par la mort
de cette élite repliée sur elle-même qui
s'arroche tous les pouvoirs sans
répondre au mots qui touchent la
majorité des Français l'école de la
République souffre elle des coûts
budgétaires et des réductions d'effectif
que votre gouvernement lui impose au nom
de la RGPP elle pâtie également des
conceptions pédagogique rétrograde que
votre gouvernement encore lui assigne
pour des raisons essentiellement
idéologiques comment s'étonner dans ces
conditions que 150000 jeunes sortent
chaque année du système éducatif sans
qualification comment s'étonner du taux
d'échec universitaire record et comment
s'étonner enfin que les discours
communautaires séduisent une part
croissante de la population dès lors que
l'école n'est plus en mesure de répondre
à la peur du chômage et de la
précarité comment donner espoir à ces
jeunes qui réussissent de brillantes
études mais qui se heurent encore et
toujours au mur de leur origine ou de
leur couleur de
peau l'idéal républicain que promeuvent
les les membres du RDSE est absolument
incompatible avec la logique de repli
sur soi et de négation des valeurs de
tolérance d'ouverture aux autres et
d'acceptation des différences qui font
la tradition de notre pays le
communitarisme est non seulement un leur
mais encore un symptôme
auquel votre gouvernement ne répond que
par la méfiance envers autrui comme l'a
illustré de façon patente le débat sur
l'identité nationale que vous avez
conduit avec une rare
célérité nous avons tous pu constater
avec amertume que ce débat a produit des
effets extrê exactement inverses de ceux
escomptés puisque le Front National
s'est retrouvé une vigueur nouvelle
monsieur le ministre nous désabrouvons
avec force la politique de votre
gouvernement
pardon en matière d'immigration et
d'intégration mes collègues Anne-Marie
Escoffier et Jacques mzard vous l'ont
déjà dit à cette tribune votre politique
du chiffre et de de l'obsession
statistique n'est pas à la hauteur de
notre tradition humaniste elle ne
produit que rencœur méfiance envers
autruille et discrimination au lieu au
lieu de construire le nouveau modèle
d'intégration dont notre République a
besoin pour bâtir l'avenir les
dispositifs de lutte contre les
discriminations demeure insuffisant et
je remercie ici notre collègue Bariza
Kari de donner l'occasion au Sénat de
débattre une fois encore sur ce sujet
l'histoire de la France a démontré que
le repli sur soi ne pouvait constituer
une solution durable bien au contraire
nous avons toujours chèrement payé les
soubressau Identitaires la montée de
l'extrémisme aux récentes élections doit
nous alerter et nous mobiliser c'est au
contraire lorsqu'elle a su accueillir et
intégrer toujours à avec raison et
responsabilité que la France a avancé et
éclaircit son avenir fier de sa
tradition d'humanisme et de tolérance
attentif au respect des valeurs
fondamentales de la République les
sénateurs radicaux de gauche et
l'ensemble du groupe du RDSE
condamneront toujours avec force toutes
les forces de discrimination et saura se
mobiliser pour faire reculer le fléau
qui obère l'avenir de notre pays et de
nos
compatriotes merci mon chers collègue
dans la suite du débat la parole est au
président de la commission des lois
Jean-Jacques hest monsieur le
Président ave la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai entendu j'ai écouté avec
plaisir pour certaines interventions un
peu moins pour d'autres parce que ce
sont des réquisitoires qui ne font pas
débat puisque les choses sont
tranchées notamment d'abord ce qu'a dit
madame marisari je crois que il y a
beaucoup de choses que je peux retenir
il y en a un peu moins parce que les
aspects critiques sur la politique
gouvernementale ne ne me paraissent
pas exact car des efforts ont été faits
et je rappelle que la loi est quand même
de 2000 4 créant l'AL par exemple c'est
une loi 2004 on peut dire oui il y avait
une directive et cetera enfin c'est en
2004 entre 1999 et 2004 qui avait pu
avoir un peu de temps non mais
franchement je pense que toute façon on
a tous intérêt dans ce Parlement à être
unanime pour lutter contre les
discriminations et pas dire vous nous on
fait mieux on ferait mieux je pense que
c'est l'intérêt commun j'ai été
extrêmement sensible par contre à ce
qu'a dit Madame
et d'ailleurs vous je crois que ça a été
applaudi sur tous les bancs car on est
en train de
confondre inégalité et
discrimination parfois c'est pas la même
chose oui oui mais de temps en temps et
la proporion franchement de certains
organismes à vouloir nous faire mélanger
les deux ou certains propos les
inégalités existent dans une
société mais attendez
c'est pas forcément des
discriminations parce qu'autrement si on
dit que toute inégalité est une
discrimination je crois que on ne
comprend plus rien car les
discriminations et d'ailleurs c'est
prévu d'être réprimé les discriminations
par la loi vous avez rappelé madame
carie qu' y avait 23 incriminations dans
le code pénal qui visent des
discriminations diverses et c'est
celles-là qui sont visées bien entendu
je pense qu'il y a un vrai problème dans
notre société alors madame diny a
presque fait de la
philosophie si on et moi je vais en
faire un petit peu mais à titre
personnel si vous le permettez si on
considérait non pas des individus mais
des personnes quel qu'elles soit qui ont
droit toutes à notre respect et plus
elles sont en difficulté plus parfois je
pense au handicapés plus elles ont
besoin de respect dans notre société je
pense que nous serions sur une voie
différente que que celle qui est de
dire il faut revendiquer des droits et
cetera c'est le la société toute
entière qui doit respecter toutes les
personnes toutes les personnes et je
crois que c'est une
philosophie qui a été développée à une
certaine époque et qui pourrait
contribuer quand même
au aux valeurs de notre société et
d'ailleurs ell rejoignent tout à fait fa
les valeurs ce que dit le préambule du
1789 ou même le préambule qu'on oublie
quand même de la le premier article de
la Constitution 1958 car que que doit
faire la
loi que doit faire un pays la France je
rappelle c'est la l'article 1er
de la cons de la constitution de 58
assure l'égalité devant la loi de tous
on met les citoyens
mais même ceux qui sont pas citoyens
ceux qui résident dans notre pays et
c'est pour ça que nous avz mis le
Défenseur des droits et par le défenseur
des citoyens je vous rappelle dans
l'article 711 de la Constitution c'est
l'initiative du Sénat vous vous en
souvenez les distinction sans
distinction d'origine de race ou de
religion et ensuite on a indiqué que la
loi favorise l'égalité et on a ajouté
dans la dernière révision
constitutionnelle non seulement
politique mais dans le domaine social
les professionnels donc je crois
que alors on dit il y a rien de fait ben
non c'est pas vrai al on me dit bah les
internats d'excellence c'est pas sérieux
bah ça marche mais les écoles de la
deuxè chance ça marche mais un certain
nombre de disposition pour permettre à
des jeunes de trouver un avenir parce
que effectivement ils ont été lâchés sur
le bord de la route ça marche mais les
discriminations c'est pas ça c'est celle
que vous avez dit Madame carry quand un
diplômé
ég on lui dit non vous n'avez pas
d'emploi moi j'ai connu ces CASL et
d'ailleurs un jeune qui était dans ce
cas je lui ai dit il avait un diplôme de
3e cycle d'urbanisme il trouvait pas de
travail dans un dans les cabinets privés
je lui a dit passe le concours il est je
peux vous dire urbanisme maintenant il a
fait une très belle carrière dans
l'administration parce que c'est un
endroit où jusqu'à présent et il faut
maintenir cela c'est quand
même les concours toutes les méthodes de
recrutement sont absolument ouverte à
tous quel que soit leur origine et
cetera et il faut il faut quand même
maintenir ça alors on a beaucoup parlé
de des haut emplois de la fonction
publique
euh j'allais dire bizarrement j'ai
impression que en supprimant le le rend
de classement à la sortie on aggrave
demain la cooptation je le dis c'est une
réflexion qu'on pourra avoir bientôt
puisque c'était la volonté de certains
mais moi je pense que c'est positif tout
ce qui a été fait pour l'accès aux
grandes écoles on va y arriver pour les
boursiers et aussi à sciencep qui est
quand même une réussite et je crois que
ça ce sont des éléments efficaces pour
permettre à des jeunes et puis ça un
effet d'entraînement parce que les on
montre souvent ce qui est négatif mais
quand on montre les les exemples
positifs je pense que ça ça permet de
lutter contre les
discriminations c'est pourquoi moi je
pense que ça doit être c'est un combat
permanent quand on idéalise le passé la
France ouverte et cetera ceux qui ont
fait un peu d'histoire ou d'histoire
récente ou d'histoire ouvrière savent
par exemple combien les Polonais ont été
bien accueillis dans les mines de l'Est
à l'époque ou ou ou d'autres populations
faut quand même pas il y a un problème
c'est vrai que dans notre il y a des
aggravations qui se sont produites
et et sans doute les l'urbanisation ne
croyez pas non plus qu'il y a pas de
discrimination
géographique et que le monde rural est
exemp de difficultés rares il est plus
difficile pour un enfant qui vit dans un
canton reculé même quelquefois
d'île-de-fance d'accéder aux études
autant aussi difficile aussi difficile
et même parfois plus difficile que pour
certains citadins qui ont le horaire et
et qui peuvent accéder facilement à des
établissements de qualité ou à
l'université ça fait partie aussi des
inégalité je dirais territoriale qu'il
ne faudrait pas complètement oublier
voilà monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues j'aurais un mot à dire quand
même parce que ça a été évoqué de la
Haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations et pour l'égalité euh
j'ai regardé depuis 5 ans avec attention
les rapports de cette institution
euh d'ailleurs il y a des choses
extrêmement intéressantes qui sont
confirmées d'ailleurs parce que vous
avez dit le trajectoire et origine les
études fait par lined et et
Linc on s'aperçoit que les
discriminations sont beaucoup plus
différenciées qu'on le pense et sans
doute par exemple laalde a découvert que
l'inégalité pour les femmes
enceintes
était particulièrement par rapport au
nombre quelque chose de tout à fait
significatif et pourtant il y a il y a
un droit du travail il y a des règles
absolues B je pense aussi qu'il faut que
la justice
aussi prenne ses responsabilités et que
les gens n'hésitent pas non plus ça peut
pas être une autorité indépendante qui
règle tous les sujets et d'ailleurs je
regrette deux choses c'est d'une part
quand on nous dit il y a 10000 dossiers
à la Hal en fin de compte il n'y en a
que 1000 qui sont traités parce que les
autres ça c'est pas de la responsabilité
de la
et quand on fait le filtre et cetera de
ce qui reste il y a des choses bien il y
a des choses un petit peu secondaires et
je regrette qu'il a pas plus de
transmission au Parquet que 12
transmission au Parquet ça veut dire on
veut régler les problèmes entre nous
sans faire appel à la justice je pense
que c'est quand même la justice qui
doit faire appliquer la loi quand elle
n'est pas appliquée je le dis et moi
vous sa j'étais assez hostile à tous ces
médiations et cetera parce que c'est
quand même le rôle de la justice de
faire appliquer les lois et sur dans ce
domaine là comme dans les autres et
puis nous aurons à discuter vous saz
qu'il faut pas faire de débat
préparatoire avant un projet de loi donc
nous aurons à discuter du Défenseur des
droits je pense quand même que si vous
relisez bien l'article
711 le Défenseur des droits c'est plus
un super médiateur ça n'est plus un
super médiateur il aura des pouvoirs
beaucoup plus important alors on peut
discuter du
périmètre mais est-ce qu'on a intérêt à
multiplier et à continuer de multiplier
les autorités administratives
indépendantes vous savez que ça n'est
pas le sentiment mais déjà ancien de la
commission des loi hein je crois que il
faut d'abord peut-être progressivement
agréger comme ça existe dans beaucoup de
démocratie je pense au défenseurs des
droits espagnols ou JEP je pense à
certains un certain nombre d'embutsman
qui effectivement ont des pouvoirs aussi
importants que ce notre nouveau
défenseur des droits mais en même temps
qui a qui défendent tous les droits et
les droits à l'égalité est un droit
fondamental comme les
autres merci monsieur le président de la
commission des
lois la parole est à Claude Jean pour le
groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur une des des
dimensions de la lutte contre les
discriminations il porte sur un droit
fondamental
acquis depuis l'adoption des lois kyot
en 82 et bison en 90 c'est le droit au
logement il est un droit évidemment
fondamental ce droit vous le savez
devenu opposable avec la loi d'Allo en
2007 et malgré les nombreux dispositifs
juridiques en place force est de
constater que le droit le droit effectif
au logement est tenu en échec et les
discriminations d'accès au logement se
manifeste le très souvent elle s'incarne
en en particulier dans la concentration
des populations d'origine étrangère
réelle ou supposé dans certaines zones
géographiques ou certaines communes
favorisant ainsi de véritables ghos ce
n'est pas le le maire de Mulous qui me
démentira tout le monde partage au moins
sur le plan des principes la volonté
d'une vraie mixité sociale celle-ci
constitue un des remparts les plus
efficaces contre la discrimin nation
c'est pourquoi nous sommes conscients
que l'accès sans discrimination au
logement relève pour une large part de
la responsabilité des bailleurs sociaux
et des bailleurs privés et à ce titre je
souhaite saluer le partenariat engagé
entre l'Union Sociale de l'habitat et la
Haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations la publication fin 2009
d'un guide des procédures d'attribution
de logements sociaux intégrant une
contribution de
laalde la transparence dans les
procédures d'attribution constitue
autant de canaux nécessaires à
l'objectif de mixité sociale dans ce
cadre
elle doit cependant rester
cette objectif de mixité sociale un
objectif permanent de progrès pour les
bailleurs sociaux cette exigence devrait
pourrait aussi faire l'objet d'une
transparence plus effective de la de la
part des bailleurs proposant des
logements conventionné pour autant nous
ne pouvons nous satisfaire de la
situation actuelle l'éradication des
discrimination en matière de logement ne
saurait reposer que sur la bonne volonté
des bailleurs sociaux et des bailleurs
privés la France s'est dotée d'outils
juridiques complets pour favoriser la
mixité sociale me direz-vous et vous
aurez raison depuis la loi sur la
solidarité et le renouvellement urbain
du 13 décembre 2000 imposant le fameux
20 % de logements sociaux dans les
communes de plus de 3500 habitants
jusqu'à la loi
ENL du 13 juillet 2006 et enfin la loi
de mobilisation pour le logement et la
lutte contre l'exclusion dite Loi Boutin
pour l'accès au logement adopté le 25
mars 2009 on voit que l'arsenal
législatif est important mais la réalité
observable montre que les mécanismes
tendant à éviter les discriminations au
logement sont inefficaces ou pour le
moins insuffisants en effet selon le
comité régional de l'habitat et pour ne
prendre qu'une seule région
l'île-de-fance 44 % des communes de
cette région soit 3 soit 83/
181 ne respect pas la loi SRU et son
objectif de 20 % voilà encore une
volonté du législateur qui faute de
volontarisme politique n'est pas suivi
d' faits alors quelle mesure convient-il
de mettre en œuvre pour lutter contre
les discriminations observées au titre
de l'accès au logement le rapport de
laalde en 2009 et l'association ses
racisme propose plusieurs catégories de
mesures pour promouvoir cette égalité
pour éviter la concentration des
populations d'origine étrangère dans les
secteurs les plus défavorisés ce qui
constitue par définition une
discrimination organisée diverses
actions sont nécessaires je souhaiterais
vous en soumettre quelques-unes la liste
n'est évidemment pas exhaustive la
construction d'abord et surtout la
réhabilitation de logements sociaux
supplémentaires il s'impose aujourd'hui
assurer cela va de so
un meilleur respect de la loi su par
l'augmentation conséquente des pénalités
et par la réquisition de logements
sociaux dans les villes ne respectant
pas la loi nous avons fait des
propositions dans ce sens le rachat de
logements privés par les offices HLM
dans les villes où il n'y a plus de
place pour construire des logements
sociaux l'obligation aussi pour chaque
nouvel ensemble de logement privé de
comporter en son sein 20 % de logement à
loyer modéré et je pourrais ainsi
poursuivre les mesures disponibles et
que vous connaissez ne manque pas enfin
et je veux insister sur ce point il il y
a lieu sans doute de tirer un premier
bilan de la loi d'allau il semble en
effet qu'un des effets pervers de cette
disposition législative et on peut le
vérifier au travers des indicateurs
produits concentre de fait les demandes
de logement émanant de personnes
défavorisées sur certaines zones
géographiques souvent les mêmes alors
Monsieur le Ministre et je conclus il ne
faut pas seulement des lois pour
endiguer les discriminations elles sont
naturellement nécessaires mais il faut
une volonté il faut surtout une
véritable instrumentation pour les
appliquer c'est le résultat que nous
attendons de ce débat je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
touch pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
discrimination est une inégalité de
traitement fondé sur un critère prib par
la loi comme l'origine le sexe le
handicap dans des domaines divers comme
l'emploi le logement
l'éducation notre législation en matière
de lutte contre les discriminations a
donné lieu à une multitude de textes qui
ont considérablement élargi le champ des
infractions et ont voulu en favoriser la
répression les agissements incriminés
concernent des mesures défbloraable à la
personne s'estimant victime de cette
dérive le plus souvent dans des échanges
économiques ou dans le travail les
dispositions législatives relatives à la
preuve et au moyens de défense des
personnes concernées ont également été
conçus ou réformés pour encourager
l'action des victimes je tenais
naturellement à cette occasion à saluer
la récente nomination de Jeanette
bourade à la tête de la Hal et aussi
saluer le travail accompli par son
prédécesseur lis fzer comme vous le
savez cette autorité soutient et met en
œuvre des actions de prévention des
discriminations et de promotion de
l'égalité avec l'ensemble des acteurs
administration entreprise association
partenaires sociaux la saisine n'est
d'ailleurs directe par n'importe quel
citoyen qui peut exercer un recours s'il
se sent discriminé et je rappelle madame
Kar comme le disait le président yes
tout à l'heure que ce texte a été voté
sous le gouvernement raparin donc ça
veut dire c'est une volonté du
gouvernement et du Parlement de soutenir
ce texte nous sommes convaincus que la
remise en cause des stéréotypes et des
préjugets passe par la mobilisation des
acteurs de tous les domaines où peuvent
apparaître des discriminations c'est
dans cela que l'action d'Alde est forte
car elle encourage ses partenaires à
développer de bonnes pratiques il est du
devoir de chacun et de nous-même élus de
nous employerer vérifier qu'il s'agisse
d'accès à l'emploi au logement d'accès
au au biens et au services d'accès à
l'éducation ces dernières années
beaucoup d'initiatives ont été prises
pour changer la donne je pense par
exemple à science politique qui a été
évoqué à l'Institut Montaigne qui a
mobilisé plus de 2000 entreprises autour
des engagements de sa charte de la
diversité à certaines écoles de commerce
qui ont mis en place des mécanismes de
tutorat pour apporter aux jeunes des
quartiers défavorisés le soutien de ceux
qui ont réussi au lycées qui ont
instauré des formations pour aider les
élèves de conditions modestes à intégrer
les classes préparatoires au cordé de la
réussite lancé pour établir davantage de
passerell entre les établissements
scolaires les grandes écoles et les
universités ces initiatives déterminées
sont encourageante mais c'est l'ensemble
de notre société qu'il faut mettre en
mouvement pour favoriser la promotion
sociale monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous préciser les récentes mesures que
le Gouvernement a engagé en matière de
lutte contre les discriminations dans le
domaine de l'emploi et du handicap et de
la manière dont sont prises en compte
les victimes de discrimination je vous
remercie merci mon chers
collègu dans la suite du débat la parole
est à Jean-Étienne Antoinette apparenté
au groupe socialiste mon chers
collègue nous vous
écoutons
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
ministe chers collègues j'ai souhaité
m'inscrire dans ce débat introduit par
notre collègue carie afin d'interpeller
le gouvernement sur l'état d'avancement
au plan législatif de la politique en
faveur de l'égalité des chances des
Français
d'autrem cette politique na émergé que
tout récemment avec la mise en place de
la délégation d'idier du même
dans un contexte où la notion d'identité
nationale est totalement dévoyée la
situation des ultramarins apporte un
éclairage particulier sur les
discriminations liées aux origines
ethniques ou territoriales en effet les
discriminations subies par les
ultramarins ne peuvent être attachées
aux barrières linguistiques culturelles
religieuses ou de nationalité ces
problématiques auxquelles on
souhaiterait parfois réduire de façon
caricaturale les causes des
inégalités nous parlons donc bien de
français de générations multiséculair
vivant des situations pour une pass
similaire à celle subie par les
personnes étrangères ou issu de
l'immigration cela en raison très
clairement de leur morphotype ou de leur
région d'origine notamment dans l'accès
à l'emploi au logement ou même aux soins
comme si la carte Vitale par exemple ne
ferait pas les mêmes garanties sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
d'autres discriminations sont
surdéterminés par les situations propres
aux régions et collectivités d'autres m
au regard de la métropole ainsi
l'éloignement les différences de niveau
de vie le coût de mobilité la fracture
numérique les difficultés d'accès aux
études supérieur crée des inégalités
bien insuffisamment corrigées par les
politiques publiques en 2007 par exemple
seul 18 % des étudiants boursiers du
Yanet avaient accès à logement du CROUS
et l'an dernier les bandes de passage
attribuant les billets d'avion de ces
étudiants étaient supprimés brutalement
sans préparation des familles concernés
et sans que ce soit déjà mis en place
les nouveaux dispositifs d'aide à la
mobilité ou ou de continuité
territoriale qui sont loin de bénéficier
de toutes les personnes concernées enfin
certaines de ces discriminations sont
légales ell résulent du fonctionnement
même des institutions et des
organisations de la République parce
qu'elles sont par des principes
structurels réputés égalitaires mais de
fait discriminant ces derniers en effet
ne tiennent pas compte des réalités ou
des handicaps de départ de certains il
onê ainsi des mobilités de sélection
pour l'entrée dans les écoles
d'excellence des procédure d'accès et de
déroulement des concours y compris dans
la fonction publique de certaines
réglementations défavorables à une
réelle égalité des chances d'accéder aux
différentes ressources nationales comme
le sont ces dispositifs applicable en
outre M ou tardivement adapté depuis 2
ou 3 ans ces réalités sont reconnues par
les pouvoirs publics et on peut saluer
le travail de la délégation pour
l'égalité des chances des Français
d'outrem cette dernière a permis de
mettre en exerg la multiplicité des
inégalités et des discriminisations qui
se conjuguent dans le concours des
ultramarins depuis leur métropole
d'origine jusque dans leur vie
quotidienne en métropole la mission
d'information sur les domes du Sénat et
les états généraux de l'outrem ont
également porté un éclairage important
dans plusieurs domaines en
2009 cependant au-delà des constats
l'analyse des dispositifs mis en place
récemment ou des mesures annoncées par
le Président de la République lors du
COM de novembre dernier ressemble encore
à des tentatives épars de limiter ici et
là les effets les plus grossiers de ces
discriminations ou les injustices
systémiques systémiques les plus
flagrantes plutôt qu'à l'élaboration
d'une politique volontariste réelle
visant à les corriger à la base par
exemple l'interdiction du refus d'une
caution résident en are ma constitue une
avancée juridique importante mais quelle
en est l'efficacité réelle lorsque les
fraiss à l'accès au logement sont
ailleurs que les discriminations selon
l'origine se poursuivent de façon
détourné ou encore toujours dans le
logement qu'attendre de la possibilité
de déposer un dossier de depuis sa
région d'origine pour ultramarin en voie
de déménagement lorsque le fichage des
origines ethnraciales ou territorial
sont les outils mêmes de la
discrimination chez le bailleur d'autre
part nombre de dispositifs intéressants
auou demeurant relève de partenariats de
conventions et autres charartes de la
diversité tels que la convention du
Centre national des œuvres
universitaires et scolaires avec les
diverses régions et collectivités prises
séparément les chartes signées par un
collectif de grandes entreprises trois
compagnies aériennes ou quelques grandes
écoles autant d'engagements pris sur les
bases de la bonne volonté des uns ou des
autres apparaissent comme de beaux
gestes là il faudrait l'affirmation du
droit on met en place sous des formes
non coeritives sans moyen
supplémentaires de sanctionner les
délits des démarches qui laissent en
l'état de les structures de la société
ne changeant rien au fonctionnement même
des institutions qui devrait garantir
l'égalité c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
sans m connaître l'intérêt des actions
menées tout àimut par la Délégation
interministérielle à l'égalité des
chances des Français d'utres m j'estime
vital pour le pacte républicain que le
droit prennent ou reprennne sa place
toute sa place dans la lutte contre les
discriminations et j'élargis ici mon
propos contre toutes les discriminations
qu'ell soit direct ou indirect or on
sait la difficulté qu'il y a à prouver
une discrimination direct même lorsque
l'action est ortée par une association
reconnue on sait aussi la difficulté la
difficile lecture par les parquets des
faits de discrimination quand il s'agit
de les caractériser tant il est facile
pour leur hauteur de biser voilà donc
mes questions s'agissant du processus
d'égalisation des chances pour les
ultramarins comp passeant du stade des
conventions des chartes et autres gestes
charitables un réel renouvellement des
politiques publiques et du
fonctionnement des organisations en
matière d'éducation de logement des
déroulements des carrières de continuité
territoriale de diffusion culturelle et
enfin s'agissant des discriminations
directes quel moyens supplémentaire le
gouvernement compte-il donner aux
instances compétentes t la Halde mais
surtout au parquet pour faire évoluer la
prise en charge des dossiers des
pignants afin que la loi garantisse
enfin
véritablement le respect du pacte
républicain merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à notre collègue
Martial Bourquin pour le groupe
socialiste dernier orateur inscrit dans
ce
débat monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues
moi aussi je remercie sincèrement ma
collègue barizakari d'avoir une fois de
plus remis l'ouvrage sur le métier en
interpellant notre assemblée sur la
lutte contre les discriminations en
effet des piqures de rappel simpos sans
cesse d'une part parce que comme les
intervenants l'ont rappelé les
l'exclusion prend des formes à la fois
variées et changeantes d'autre part
parce que l'égalité pourtant inscrite
sur le fronton de nos mairies n'est pas
naturel
elle est le fruit d'un travail
quotidien difficile toujours
enthousiasment jamais
satisfaisant surtout lorsque des
discours politiques dont certains
apparence tout à fait respectable
s'applique à adresser différentes
catégories de population les unes contre
les autres en espérant en tirer un
quelconque avantage électoral comme mes
collègues je je dois dire que j'étis
choqué profondément choqué
par le débat sur l'identité nationale
que le gouvernement a initié à
l'initiative de Monsieur Besson en
quelques mois sous prétexte de libérer
les paroles et les initiatives j'ai vu
des actions pour l'égalité réalisé dans
la discrétion par des travailleurs
sociaux par des militants associatifs
par des élus des pères et mères
considérablement mise à mal en quelques
jours c'est un véritable
gâi comment comment pouvions-nous
ignorer que la crise économique et
sociale d'une telle
ampleur un langage comme celui-ci un
débat comme celui-ci ne ferait que
attiser des réflexes bien connus de peur
de rejet de l'autre de faire exacerber
le sentiment d'injustice ainsi que la
tendance à
l'autodiscrimination je comprends
toujours pas que le gouvernement a pris
une t responsabilité de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu de jouer à
l'apprentisorcier dans un contexte
humain économique et social que nul
n'est vraiment en capacité de
maîtriser je crois que le gouvernement a
présumé de ses forces là où les exemples
historiques sont pourtant si nombreux de
ce lien si connexte entre crise
économique désespoir social et rejet de
l'autre le cocktail désindustrialisation
massive exclusion précarité
et débat sur l'identité nationale a
abouti il y a quelques jours à ce que de
nouveau le Front national réapparaisse
fortement dans des quartiers parfois
arrivant devant la
majorité présidentielle actuelle les
discriminations pire encore le sentiment
de ne plus faire partie de la communauté
nationale ont décidément connu une année
très noire les signaux d'alerte sont en
effet très inquiets an dimanche 14 et 21
mars 70 % des habitants des quartiers
difficiles ne se sont pas déplacé pour
voter 80 % au premier tour issu de la
France dite visible comme celle de la
France de souche cher à notre collègue
Longuet ces populations ont exprimé par
un silence
assourdissant un message d'une violence
rare en agissant ainsi et aussi
massivement ces habitants se sont
volontairement placés hors de la
République hors de la communauté
nationale hors de la société en actant
d'une certaine façon le fait que cette
société ne voulait pas deeux à ces
habitants que je côoie souvent par mes
responsabilités de Mare d'une commuse de
15000 habitants avec plusieurs quartiers
sensibles et particulièrement au plus
jeunes j'aimerais pouvoir dire ce que
disait André Gide il y a
d'admirable possibilité en chaque
être persuade-toi de ta force de ta
jeunesse sche te redire sans cesse il ne
tient qu'à toi mais je ne veux pas leur
mentir à ces jeunes ces jeunes gens qui
vivent qui viennent souvent au mairie
demander de l'aide ont tout fait tout au
long de leur existence parfois de
manière à s'intégrer mieux dans la
Société des études des formations des
multiplications de formations parfois un
comportement exemplaire des prises de
responsabilité dans la vie associative
ils sont intégrés dans la vie
associative et culturelle ils veulent de
toutes leurs force accéder à une vie
normale paisible payer des impôts tout
simplement accéder à un premier emploi
et tout cela des choses toutes simples
pour nous représentent un véritable
chemin de croix pour eux bien sûr il y a
quelques exemples médiatiques qui
montrent que une tel ou un tel
originaire de quartier difficile a si
bien réussi et ces mêmes exemples
exceptionnels les renvoie à leur propre
échec et les rend personnellement
responsable de tout alors il y a des
initiatives et barisa et d'autres
intervenants tout à l'heure sont
intervenus dans ce domaine le CV anonyme
qui peut lever des barrières faut-il ou
non généraliser cette c'est une vraie
question qu'il faut que nous mettions au
cœur de nos débats je crois cependant
que le moyen le plus efficace pour
briser ces barrières c'est le proposer
un travail en nombre et très vite
intervenir de façon massive dans les
quartiers pour travailler non pas pour
travailler plus et gagner plus
simplement travailler juste travailler
obtenir ce fameux premier emploi pour se
stabiliser pour rebondir et parfois
commencer sa vie normalement comme
chacune et chacun d'entre nous le
dispositif par exemple des zones
franches urbaines est à mon sens trop
peu efficace pour crée une dynamique
nécessaire ça crée plutôt des effets
d'obè chez moi j'ai pu constater que
ménagement déménagement fiscal des
professions libérales qui s'implantent
dans les zones franches et désertent les
centr-villees on empoche l'argent de la
défiscalisation et parfois on se
regroupe et on supprime des
emplois les contreparties de de ces
zones franches en terme d'emploi sont
très faies trop faibles et les contrôles
souvent
anecdoti pour pouvoir redresser la-bas
là aussi je ne veux pas critiquer ces
ces comment ces professions libérales
c'est est humain il profite d'une loi
qui est en vigueur mais je crois que la
loi devrait être beaucoup plus
restrictive pour empêcher ces
déménagements de centr-ville mais
surtout ça paraît un affront pour ces
jeunes des quartiers qui n'ont pas de
travail et qui voient une
défiscalisation qui qui se compte
parfois en centaines de milliers d'euros
jusqu'à maintenant je veux le dire et ce
n'est pas un a
priori politique pour partisan j'ai mené
une politique qui s'appelait la
politique des emplois jeunes et je dois
vous dire que j'en ai j'en 35 dans une
ville de 15000 habitants
et ces 35 emplois jeunes à 85 % ont
débouché sur des CDI dans des
professions libérales dans le bâtiment
dans la dans dans les les employés
territoriaux et ça a été vraiment une
réussite pourquoi 5 ans le SMIC beaucoup
de formation et cela ça a fonctionné
appelez-les autrement si c'est un
problème idéologique mais faites quelque
chose dans ces quartiers parce que je
vous assure nous sommes devant une bombe
à retardement s'il n'y a pas une action
forte massive inévitablement
tous nous aurons à payer très cher cette
façon de ne pas agir voilà je je vrais
dire aussi qu'il faudrait sans doute que
l'État les services publics restent dans
ces quartiers je je prends un exemple
chez moi la poste
sur 5 jours d'ouverture un jour de moins
je sais que dans quelques mois elle me
proposera une agence communale pour
prendre en charge tout cela n'est pas de
bonne augure il faut que les services
publics restent dans ces quartiers comme
ils doivent rester dans la ruralité
comme cétait dit tout à l'heure voilà
chers colèg ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui je finirai en disant que
l'abé pierre disait on ne peut pas sous
prétexte qu'il est impossible de ne rien
faire un jour ne rien faire du tout et
bien la lutte contre les discriminations
c'est la lutte pour la dignité humaine
et un autre proverbe asiatique disait si
tu donnes un poisson à un homme il
mangera un jour si tu lui apprends à
pêcher il mangera toujours et bien chers
collègues nous avons le devoir de donner
une chance à ces femmes à ces jeunes à
ces hommes qui ne veulent que tout
simplement vivre comme tout le monde
merci mon cher
collègue la parole
estire
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice barisa Kari je veux tout
d'abord excuser mon collègue Éric Besson
qui est retenu au Conseil des ministres
qui se tient
exceptionnellement l'après-midi
aujourd'hui et qui présente vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous-même souligné un projet
de loi relatif à l'immigration à
l'intégration et la
nationalité je vais donner quelques
éléments de
réponse à votre intervention liminaire
c'est normal et ensuite essayer de
reprendre non pas la totalité de ce que
vous avez pu dire les uns et les autres
qui était fort intéressant mais chaque
fois l'un ou l'autre élément pour
essayer de de vous répondre au mieux moi
je me sens à titre personnel très
concerné par ce sujet quelqu'un le
rappelé tout à l'heure je suis maire de
mulouse et c'est une ville dans laquelle
depuis plus de 20 ans euh et avec des
gouvernements successifs comme
partenairirees d'ailleurs de toute
sensibilité politique je fais un un
travail approfondi euh pas tout seul
d'ailleurs hein avec mes collègues avec
que le monde associatif le monde
économique et je sais combien et donc
c'est un sujet sur lequel je m'exprime
je ne peux m'exprimer qu'avec une
certaine humilité parce que je sais
combien la question est
difficile en même temps avec humilité
mais en même temps et c'est un point de
vue que je partage avec tous sur tous
les bancs c'est une exigence que nous
puissions sur ces questions et notamment
euh sur la la lutte contre les
discriminations et notamment ces
discriminations là même S ne sont pas
les seuls loin sans faux continuer à à
progresser et et accélérer le rythme en
même
temps je sais
aussi que la
discrimination
contribue à l'esprit de de victimisation
qui parfois amène à baisser les bras ou
à ne voir que ce qu'il y a négatif dans
une société dans un environnement et que
cette victimisation ne favorise pas
l'intégration donc au fond là aussi on
se rend compte qu'il faut agir sous tous
les leviers si on encourage ce sentiment
d'ailleurs on ne le fait pas les uns les
autres lorsque on est au contact avec
ces personnes on ne les aide pas et en
même temps parfois il faut bien
reconnaître nous le vivons tous que
certaines personnes qui ont fait des
efforts sont
confronté malgré ses efforts à des
obstacles multiples donc nous avons du
pas sur la planche je dis ça parce que
j'ai préféré en vous écoutant madame
Kari les
aspect concret de de votre propos un
certain nombre de propositions que
parfois
une un jugement que j'ai trouvé par trop
systématique voire parfois un peu
caricatural mais là aussi je le dis avec
nuance parce que mon propos n'est pas de
de fustiger ce que vous avez pu dire
mais d'aller d'ambler comme tous nous le
souhaitons au fond des choses je
voudrais d'abord vous assurer du profond
engagement du gouvernement en faveur de
la lutte contre les discriminations et
dire que je partage avec vous tous la
conviction que la République se doit
garantir la plus grande justice pour
tous et notamment ceux qui sont au but
au plus de difficultés l'acceptation des
différences qui traverse une société et
notre société est une opportunité pour
elle de devenir plus forte parce que
plus humaine plus efficace plus juste
nous sommes tous différents et j'ai
envie d'ajouter aussitôt et tous égaux
mais nous sommes tous porteurs ou
héritiers de différence la volonté de
notre peuple c'est de marcher vers la
plus grande intransigence vis-à-vis de
ces discriminations et les représentants
du peuple que vous êtes nous font
comprendre que c'est aussi votre volonté
la lutte pour l'égalité des chances
c'est d'ailleurs un des engagements
forts
du président de la République qui
rappelait dans son discours de paliso en
citant clémenenceau que la République
n'est rien qu'un instrument
d'émancipation un instrument d'évolution
par l'éducation de tous c'est vrai que
certains d'entre vous l'ont dit j'y
reviendrai d'ailleurs en évoquant leur
intervention que les interventions ne
concernent pas que les jeunes issus d'
l'immigration j'y reviendrai parce que
c'était l'essentiel de votre
interprélation mais le genre l'âge le
handicap l'apparence physique
l'orientation sexuelle politique ou
confessionnel sont aussi prétexte à
discrimination et c'est vrai que la la
Halde que nous avons tous souhaités et
qui a été effectivement installé il y a
maintenant 5 ans après avoir été voté
par une loi en 2004 offre un vrai
recours et je peux aussi témoigner comme
beaucoup d'entre vous dans vos
départements dans vos villes que les
délégués locaux qui se mettent en place
prennent leur rôle très à cœur et font
connaître la halte je voudrais vraiment
saluer
très très chaleureusement l'arrivée à sa
présidence de Jeanette
Bougrab dont beaucoup connaissent
l'expérience le talent l'engagement j'ai
moi-même eu l'occasion de travailler
avec elle pendant toute la période où
j'ai siégé au au Conseil à l'intégration
avec Blandine criégel et où Jeanette
était une de nos collègues et c'est là
que j'ai pu effectivement apprécier ses
qualités sa motivation sa compétence
elle fera j'en suis persuadé un
excellent travail les discriminations
dont vous faites mention dans votre
question madame la sénatrice
effectivement concernait essentiellement
l'origine des personnes et je vais
concentrer donc mon propos sur cet
aspect le
gouvernement agit et ainsi le comité
interministériel à l'égalité des chances
tenu le 23 novembre dernier a réuni un
ensemble de ministères concernés sous
l'autorité du Premier ministre sur
différentes thématiques et notamment
celle que sur lequelle vous avez les uns
et les autres fortement insisté comme
l'emploi et c'est vrai que surtout dans
le contexte économique difficile que
nous traversons c'est un point essentiel
c'est là que l'outil le plus important a
été mis en place en tout cas le plus
emblématique c'est le label Diversité
initié par le ministère chargé de
l'intégration avec l'appui des
ministères du Travail et de l'Emploi il
est maintenant opérationnel depuis
presque 1 an et il concerne tous les
employeurs publics et privés qui doivent
justifier de de critères objectifs de de
recrutement de gestion des carrières au
fond c'est un c'est un objectif que ces
entreprise se fixe il il y a une
dimension bien sûr de volontariat mais
vous savez la force que peuvent peent
avoir les labels lorsque à un moment
donné ils sont
connus les gens savent que ce qu'il
représente et et font à un moment donné
la différence entre ceux qui
euh prennent un label ou ne le prennent
pas ça peut faire sourire au début on un
label un label bah on a vu moi qui est
maintenant un peu d'expérience de la vie
publique on a vu des labels qui au début
paraissaient un
peu comment dire
mystérieux ou peu connu et et peu à peu
monter en puissance
s'imposer être connu de l'opinion
publique à telle enseigne
que on se pose fortement la
question face là en l'occurrence à des
entreprises qui à un moment donné ne
rempliraient pas les conditions pour
pouvoir s'y référer en faire état c'est
un point important d'ailleurs la preuve
c'est que le dispositif a démarré assez
fort
en quelques mois c'est déjà pas loin
d'une centaine d'entreprises qui sont
labellisées plus de 500000 salariés qui
sont concernés et ce n'est que le tout
début alors il y a la question du CV
anonyme que vous avez également abordé
c'est un point important c'est un point
d'ailleurs en son temps qui avait fait
débat nous pensons qu'il peut s'avérer
un outil efficace dans la lutte contre
les discriminations à l'embauche et
c'est pourquoi le Gouvernement a
souhaité accompagner et soutenir les
entreprise qui l'expériment en interne
et c'est pourquoi
également nous nous sommes engagés avec
les différents ministères concernés le
commissaire le commissaire pardon la
diversité et avec Pôle emploi et avec un
certain nombre de cabinets de
recrutement dans une expérimentation à
grande échelle pour évaluer les effets
de cette méthode et c'est important sur
un sujet comme celui-là qui j' répète av
fait débat dans la société mais qui peut
constituer c'est en tout cas mon opinion
un levier utile de voir comment ça
fonctionne concrètement et rien ne vaut
une bonne expérimentation à la bonne
échelle se départements un nombre
important d'entreprise les résultats de
cette expérimentation qui s'achèvera en
avril seront connus d'ici juin et cela
nous permettra de nous prononcer
clairement de manière étaayée sur les
suites à donner au projet de décret et c
bien sûr après concertation entre autres
des partenaires sociaux l'action en
faveur de la diversité s'appuie aussi
sur un partenariat actif avec l'ensemble
des structures associatives qui œuvr
dans la dans le domaine de la lutte
contre les discriminations dans
l'entreprise ces associations ces
fondations elles sont connues je ne vais
pas pour ne pas alourdir et allonger mon
propos vous en faire toute la liste euh
nous les soutenons pour proposer aux
entreprises des diagnostics sur la
gestion de la diversité les aider à
formaliser des plans d'action mettre au
point des indicateurs de progrès on
n'oublie pas également la dimension
d'accès à l'apprentissage et beaucoup
peuvent témoigner ici aussi que et moi
j'ai connu des périodes parce que euh on
n'a pas toujours été dans des périodes
difficiles en matière d'emploi comme
aujourd'hui moi j'ai connu des périodes
comme il Liu local où les entreprises
cherchaient désespérément du personnel
c'est encore le cas d'ailleurs ici ou là
dans des niches et où par ailleurs la
discrimination fonctionnait à plein hein
euh parfois par pour de vraiment
mauvaises raisons parfois par peur par
ignorance et pour des raisons disons
surmontables et on se rend compte que
les initiatives qui sont prises y
compris par les Chambres Consulaires par
un certain nombre d'associations et qui
crée un effet de rencontre et qui
surmonte ce qui peut
être peur d'innover de prendre un
soi-disant risque et cetera et ensuite
la démultiplication de témoignages de
chefs d'entreprise d'artisans qui disent
mais je ne vous comprends pas mais ça se
passe très bien mais ce sont des jeunes
formidables ils sont extrêmement
motivé presque plus enfin euh bon enfin
il se passe aussi des trucs positifs à
partir du moment et heureusement
d'ailleurs c'est aussi une dé forces de
notre pays comme quelqu'un le rappelait
tout à l'heure depuis tant de
générations à partir du moment où où où
le le déclic se se fait mais il faut
arriver à à en quelque sorte le le le
provoquer et ça ça passe c'est vrai nous
sommes tous d'accord par une démarche
volontariste et c'est aussi le sens de
ces partenariats on pourrait dire
beaucoup là-dessus il y a aussi des des
conventions qui sont passées avec les
secteurs professionnels pour amplifier
cette démarche et notamment des secteurs
je parlais tout à l'heure de domaine
dans lequel on cherche encore peut-être
plus que dans des domaines en difficulté
ou en crise des des employés du
personnel pense à des secteurs comme
l'hôtellerie la restauration
l'informatique les mutuels les
assurances et dans ce domaine-là euh il
y a vraiment euh des entreprises qui
donnent l'exemple qui sont déjà
mobilisées et qui le font savoir et qui
en font même je parlais de label tout à
l'heure un élément de leur image de
marque hein de leur image vis-à-vis du
public de la clientèle qui est aussi la
réalité française telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui la clientèle hein je veux
dire parfois un intérêt bien compris va
aussi je dirais vient aussi appuyer une
démarche volontariste et
éthique mais tout ça c'est c'est aussi à
à comment dirais-je a enclencher au
niveau des des branches professionnelles
qui souvent peuvent jouer un rôle tout à
fait utile ou de certaines entreprises
qui sont un peu leaders vis-à-vis des
des autres c'est aussi des accords avec
des associations sur l'accès à l'emploi
des jeunes diplômés je vais là aussi pas
les citer mais elles sont nombreuses
elles font un travail remarquable et
c'est vrai que nous avons tous sur le
terrain dans nos villes des des
expérience de de démarche engagé avec
ces associations ou avec un certain
nombre m de d'organisations
euh nous avons
également d'autres pistes qui permettent
de favoriser la promotion des diversités
dans le respect du principe qui régit
notre constrat social puisque vous le
savez la France ne reconnaît pas de
communauté aut que la communauté
nationale et la diversité dans ces
conditions c'est d'abord une question de
femme et d'homme une question de
parcours individuel d'expérience mais ce
n'est pas une raison pour pour ne pas
agir je veux citer le prix de
l'intégration avec un jury
national et un un travail qui je crois
est tout à fait remarquable et qui
permet tout
simplement ça ne suffit pas bien sûr
quelqu'un l'a dit ça ne suffit pas les
exemples un peu emblématiques mais c'est
une manière de montrer qu'il n'y a pas
que des des des grands sportif ou des
des artistes mais qu'il y a aussi dans
la diversité des métiers hein des gens
qui méritent à un moment donné d'être
mis en exerg qui ont eu un parcours qui
mérite d'être montré en exemple et et
qui peut aussi
susciter un engouement
d'évocation et ce prix deintégration il
a ce but c'est aussi les allocations
financière des parcours de réussite
professionnelle attribué aux étudiants
issus de de l'immigration des étudiants
qui euh marquent là aussi une une
volonté euh
euh
dans un parcours scolaire universitaire
qui doit être encouragé et accompagné
alors on peut dire mais oui mais alors
tous les autres bien sûr que ce type de
de de de d'effort de geste a
aussi une
dimension je dirais de d'exemplarité et
une dimension également de de de de
lutte contre un un certain un certain
découragement qui peut parfois euh ici
ici ou là se se développer nous nous le
savons tous autre question alors là
c'est des questions vraiment extrêmement
concrètes et et dont on parle trop
peu je pense au défaut de maîtrise du
français qui est un facteur de
discrimination alors là
évidemment je je ne vise pas un certain
nombre de public que vous avez évoqué de
jeunes qui sortent du système scolaire
maîtrisant la langue comme tout un
chacun mais vous avez vous en avez
d'autres jeune ou moins jeune qui euh
vous le savez bien vivent cette
difficulté et qui sans même parler de la
question du travail hein mais complique
leur vie
quotidienne pas seulement sur l'emploi
disais-je mais également sur les soins
la vie sociale et la participation à la
vie de la de la cité et le vivre
ensemble en quelque sorte dans ce
domaine-là je ne veux pas allonger mon
propos mais un certain nombre de mesures
existent sont amplifiées pour les
migrants primo arrivants nous en avons
tous des exemples dans nos villes et et
là des efforts importants sont sont
faits notamment avec la loi du du 20
novembre 2007 et le dispositif
d'évaluation de formation des conjoints
français des bénéficiaires d'un
regroupement familial dans leur pays
d'origine relatif à la connaissance de
la langue et aux valeurs de la
République il y a également l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration qui a repris en juillet
2009 l'ensemble des formations
linguistiques qui était précédemment
financé par l'accès en faveur notamment
des personnes étrangères déjà installées
sur notre territoire et qui souhaitent
acquérir une meilleure connaissance de
notre langue pour pouvoir progresser y
compris dans le domaine de l'emploi les
efforts également faits en matière
d'enfants non francophone accueiler à
l'école moi j'avais d'ailleurs dans ma
ville en son temps créer une école
spécialisée pour ces enfants primo
arrivants où se retrouver
d'ailleurs des des des des enfants de de
de cadrees supérieur de l'économie venu
d'Écosse ou d'ailleurs et des jeunes
enfants euh venu de d'Anatolie et
c'était une démarche euh qui pendant des
années a a fort bien fonctionner tout
cela a un sens aujourd'hui le dispositif
a évolué ces classes maintenant
s'appellent les classes d'initiation
dans les écoles et elle dispose elle
dispense un enseignement intensive du
français en petit groupe à à à
différents niveaux de de scolairire il y
a également les efforts en matière
d'exercice de la parentalité euh tout
cela euh
n'est pas simple mais euh est important
c'est l'idée d'ouvrir l'école aux
parents euh on sait bien que souvent
parmi les handicaps facteur de
discrimination euh la difficulté pour
certains parents pour des raisons
linguistiques pour des raisons de
compréhension du système scolaire nous
vivons tous ça dans dans nos villes et
nos villages et bien
euh constitue dès le départ une
difficulté et et et pour ses parents et
pour leurs enfants et et et donc nous
avons là un frein à l'intégration et
tout ce qui permet de surmonter hein à
partir du volontariat des parents qui
souvent existe hein euh permet à la fois
de faciliter l'acquisition de la langue
par un anciignement complémentaire une
meilleure compréhension des principes et
des valeurs de la République une
meilleure connaissance de l'institution
scolaire des modalités d'exercice de la
parentalité et puis il y a également
toutes les actions je les cite pour
mémoire hein sans les développer de
d'accès euh au droit pour les étrangers
en matière d' d'interprétariat
traduction documents administratifs et
cetera et puis il y a la question vous
avez été plusieurs à évoquer je veux en
dire un mot de l'accompagnement des
immigrés âgés et vous avez d'ailleurs
été la première madame ensuite plusieurs
de vos collègues l'ont fait à évoquer
cette question c'est une population
effectivement spécifique bien connu que
nous avons dans dans nos villes moi-même
je je je je suis en contact avec cette
population qu'elle soit en foyer ou pas
ce sont plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de travailleurs essentiell
essentiellement maghrébains âgés qui
vivent dans ces foyers et souvent dans
les conditions que vous avez décrit de
de grande solitude sans toujours savoir
faire valoir leurs droits
et il y a il y a plusieurs réponses que
que que nous apportons que nous sommes
en train d'apporter il y a d'abord le
plan de traitement des foyers de
travailleurs migrants qui visent à les
transformer progressivement en résidence
c'est compliqué moi-même je suis
concrètement confronté à un projet comme
celui-là parce que toute transformation
même vers un mieux est une
déstabilisation au moment où ça se passe
de ces personnes qui sont déjà qui
vivent déjà dans des dans des conditions
qui sont assez précaire mais néanmoins
il faut le faire parce que souvent on a
des bâtiments qui ne sont plus au normes
qui deviennent extrêmement dangereux
enfin on n pas le choix hein mais c'est
pas facile mais ce travail est engagé il
a déjà permis la réflexion de 200 112
foyers pour un coût total de 1000
millions d'euros c'est quand même pas
rien
euh le gouvernement souhaite bien sûr
que ces travaux soient complétés par des
mesures sociales pour permettre aux
résidents d'accéder à l'ensemble des
droits et prestations y compris de soins
au-delà d'ailleurs des résident de foyer
de nombreux étrangers âgés issus des
premières vagues d'immigration vivant
souvent dans de l'habitat de mauvaise
qualité hôtel meublés quartiers ancien
dégradés et cetera demeure isolé sans
perspective de retour vers le pays
d'origine sans intention même de retour
souvent des veuves se retrouvent sans
attach dans des conditions matérielles
difficiles et aussi bien sûr il y a des
outils de socialisation des lieux de vie
qui permettent d'entretenir un lien
nécessaire au-delà de l'aspect habitat
que que j'évoqué tout à l'heure il y a
également la la la question
effectivement de de la mise en œuvre de
de de la loi c'est un point sur lequel
nous travaillons mais madame kiari tout
de même la vision euh que vous
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure en
disant des choses justes mais aussi en
disant peut-être des
choses peut-être un peu caricatural je
vous donne un exemple beaucoup de ces
personnes qui suivent des soins en
France ne souhaitent pas retourner dans
leur pays d'origine et un décret récent
permet aux bénéficiaires de de l'ASPA de
la location solidarité personnes âgé de
séjourner jusqu'à 6 mois par an hors de
France sans en perdre le le bénéfice on
peut toujours faire mieux mais enfin
c'est quand même un un un progrès quant
à l'article 58 de la loi d'Allo qui
visait à apporter une aide financière
annuel c'est vrai qu'elle se heurte à un
certain nombre de difficultés
d'application auquelle nous travaillons
en particulier sur des éventuels effets
d'extension de la mesure dans le cadre
de la législation européenne à d'autres
types de d'allocation et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous travaillons
encore à l'heure actuelle à cette à
cette mesure pour pouvoir
là-dessus euh avancer j'ai
donc donné quelques éléments de
réponse à l'instant à Madame Kari j'ai
écouté évidemment avec attention les
autres interventions très rapidement
dire à Madame DIN que le gouvernement
s'engage pleinement comme je l'ai
indiqué sur la promotion du label
Diversité et votre
intervention rappelit justement que
l'emploi est effectivement l'endroit où
une plus juste reconnaissance des
compétences
doit faire de l'entreprise comme de la
fonction publique à creuser du brassage
et de la rencontre de toutes les
différences je dis d'ailleurs au
président yest l'exemple qu'il a qu'il a
cité tout à l'heure sur la fonction
publique territoriale je pourrais en
donner de multiples témoignages nous
avons là et avec un peu de volontarisme
évidemment des collectivités un outil
puissant non seulement d'intégration
professionnelle mais également de prise
de responsabilité nous avions depuis
longtemps des cadres C enfin des des
employés de catégorie C quelques B de
plus en plus arrivent maintenant au
responsabilité concours réussi soit
d'emblé soit après une période
contractuelle avec encouragement de
préparer le concours une fois deux fois
trois fois des des des des jeunes issus
de l'immigration je dois dire pour le
moment majoritairement des femmes mais
les garçons s'y mettent également les
les choses là aussi sont en train de
changer je dis ça parce que je parle
évidemment au nom du gouvernement mais
je pense que c'est c'est tous les
responsables
employeurs qui y compris dans le secteur
public sont sont concernés par par cette
démarche et et je crois que ça vous avez
bien fait monsieur yest de le de le
souligner madame
Laborde s'est exprimé sur la
Alde en émettant un certain nombre de de
critiques par par définition soyons
exigeant mais c'est vrai que
laalde a fait un bon travail pendant ces
ces 5 années euh je peux dire d'ailleurs
que à l'époque où je présidais
l'association des grandes villes de
France j'étais la première association
d'élus à conventionné avec la Halde il y
a déjà quelques années au début hein
pour justement démultiplier sur le
terrain y compris balayer devant nos
propres portes hein nos collectivités
hein euh que ce soit en interne ou dans
nos cités dans nos villes euh le travail
de de la Halde et et je crois que euh il
ne faut pas avoir peur de la Halde il
faut au contraire euh euh vraiment jouer
le jouer le jeu de cette de cette
autorité euh madame
Assassi vous avez évoqué euh les
labyrinthes bureaucratiques de l'accès à
la nationalité
euh je souhaite quand même rappeler
quelques chiffres que vous connaissez
euh mais après je nuancerai ce que je
vais dire car je je ne vous donne pas
entièrement tort c'est tout de même plus
de de 100 108000 nouveaux Français en
2009 par naturalisation 30000 jeunes
devenis Français au titre du droit du
sol on est quand même le premier pays
d'Europe en matière d'accès à la
citoyenneté c'est une tradition
française mais elle fonctionne la nuance
que je voudrais apporter à ma réponse
c'est que c'est vrai qu'il y a ici ou là
un certain nombre de difficultés
administratives hein j'ai eu l'occasion
de l'évoquer la semaine dernière dans un
débat je ne sais plus si c'était à
l'Assemblée ou au Sénat où j'étais
également interpellé sur cette question
moi-même je dirais sur mon propre
territoire souvent hein je suis
interpellé pour pour facilité en tant
qu'élu local un certain nombre de de de
formalités donc je pense que dans ce
domaine-là en même temps je défends
l'idée que nous devons avoir des
critères hein que il faut que les choses
se fassent de manière sérieuse et on ne
peut pas non plus
aller vers des acquisitions automatiques
ça n'aurait pas de sens hein d'ailles
quand vous voyez la fierté des gens qui
ont rempli les conditions et qui
aujourd'hui viennent à nos cérémonies de
de de célébration avec le sous-préfet en
uniforme le maire et son écharpe et
cetera ce qu'on faisait pas autrefois
hein c'est une idée d'ailleurs du
Conseil à l'Intégration ça hein qui a
été ensuite reprise et mise en œuvre
c'est formidable donc c'est bien c'est
des gens aussi qui ont le sentiment
d'avoir rempli un certain nombre de
conditions fait un certain nombre
d'efforts mais il faut qu' côté de cela
certaines certains freins administratifs
ici ou là effectivement soit soit soit
surmonté je je ne vous donne pas
totalement tort à propos euh de la
question de monsieur Gautier
euh si euh nous pouvons
euh si nous ne pouvons nier que des
progrès restent à réaliser en matière
d'emploi fermé il faut tout de même euh
rel relativiser quelque peu le la
critique dès lors
que au fond et nous avons tous été
confrontés à ces questions l'accès à la
nationalité quand même relativement aisé
sauf certains cas particuliers où il y a
des difficultés permet à des personnes
motivées et ben de j'ai connu comme vous
tous des situations de surmonter cette
difficulté euh et et dans certains cas
moi je considère que cette condition se
justifie elle n'est pas elle n'est pas à
jeté aux Ortis et
euh
voilà le président yest je lui ai déjà
j'ai déjà fait référence à son
excellente intervention il a lui aussi
comme je l'ai fait au début de mon
propos rappelé aussi un certain nombre
d'exemples positifs qui sont de de de
des bons moteurs
et vous avez également pointé à juste
titre
et ça ne nous étonne pas venant du fin
juriste que vous êtes le
rôle essentiel de de la justice
lorsque des discriminations sont avérées
il faut parfois aussi que le coup pré
tombe et que on sache que que que
certains certains excès ben sont
sanctionnés quoi Monsieur géo a évoqué
avec raison la question de la mixité
sociale dans le logement le gouvernement
considère ce point comme très important
pour autant on peut ignorer les
difficultés techniques qui en freinent
l'application en situation surtout en
situation de forte tension dans le
logement social c'est le cas en
Île-de-France qui l'a cité mais
également dans dans nos
régions
Alain monsieur le sénateur Alain fucher
je crois comme Foucher pardon je crois
comme vous en la mobilisation de tous
que vous avez évoqué vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur les mesures récentes en
faveur des victimes dans le domaine de
l'emploi et du handicap je tiens à vous
préciser que les dispositions relative
aux discrimination englobe le handicap
ainsi que les seniors s'agissant
spécifiquement des personnes handicapées
l'Observatoire interministériel de
l'accessibilité a été installé vous le
savez le 11 février dernier avec pour
mission d'assurer le suivi des progrès
en matière d'accessibilité de mettre en
évidence les difficultés de centraliser
les bonnes pratiques d'informer sur les
normme d'accessibilité cet observatoire
d'ailleurs est composé notamment de
madame la sénatrice de Maresco et je
prononce bien son nom oui et
d'association de personnes handicapées
ou à mobilité réduite et c'est C
observatoire permettra une meilleure
mise en œuvre de la loi sur le handicap
du 11 février 2005 et euh nous
progressons dans notrre pays dans un
certain n de domaines même si il reste
du chemin à parcourir nous progressons
dans le domaine des transports hein
chemin de fer transport public urbain
quand je vois d'où on vient que de
progrès il en reste à accomplir c'est
certain euh en matière de
scolarisation de de nos enfants depuis
la loi 2 2005 c'est 20 % de plus
d'enfants scolarisé 180000 aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai progrès en matière
d'information également audiovisuelle
pour les déficients auditifs je je je me
suis permis de dire quelques mots
là-dessus puisque l'essentiel de notre
échange portait sur les discriminations
liées à l'origine mais je pense que il
est bon dans ce débat on aborde aussi
ces aspectsl
euh
monsieur
monsieur monsieur on m'a donné on m'a on
m'a indiqué on m'a on m' fait une erreur
en indiquant votre nom monsieur le
sénateur monsieur Antoinette
ouais non mais sur le papier on m'a mis
monsieur gtier j'ai pas parlé deux fois
monsieur Gautier je veux pas je voulais
pas me tromper d'interlocuteur et que
dans le contte-rendu de mon propos
n'est-ce pas et je vous prie de
m'excuser Monsieur le Maire de courou
monsieur le sénateur maire de courou
vous évoquez les différence et
discrimination dans son victime de
compatriote ultramarin et et vous avez
en même temps reconnu objectivement un
certain nombre de mesures positives qui
ont été mises en œuvre mais cela n'est
pas suffisant il existe de réelles
difficultés de des discriminations
directes qu'on a parfois du mal à
prouver tout ce que vous avez dit est
vrai
et ce que je peux vous dire simplement
puisque je suis là je représente le
gouvernement mais j'ai aussi la
casquette de secrétaire d'État la
justice et donc je peux vous dire avec
force que chaque fois parquet est saisi
il digante une enquête minutieuse et que
nous avons évidemment une une attention
très forte à ces à ces questions mais il
n'est pas mauvais que à travers une
intervention comme la vôtre nous ayons
temps en temps sur ce sujet important
une piqure de rappel merci de de votre
propos euh
enfin avant de finir en m'excusant
d'avoir été un tout petit peu peut-être
plus long que je ne le pensais au départ
mais vous-même vous avez aussi dit
beaucoup de choses les uns et les autres
et je voulais aussi ma fois sois par ma
réponse la plus complète possible
montrer l'importance que le gouvernement
attaché à ce débat et à vos
interventions et à cet échange dire
enfin à Monsieur Bourquin
que euh je sais pas s'il est est là que
pardon monsieur Bourquin que à à à à
titre personnel là je m'exprime à titre
personnel je suis assez d'accord avec
vous sur je je ne reprends pas ce que
vous avez dit par ailleurs et votre
plaidoyer et que j'ai trouvé fort fort
euh sincère et et intéressant mais vous
avez évoqué Infiné la question des zones
franches et des effets pervers je trouve
à titre personnel que je ne peux pas
vous donner tort je je je connais bien
cette question et et c'est vrai
que moi je suis je suis positif sur les
zone franches globalement depuis 15 ans
hein elles ont permis une réelle
transformation une amélioration
économique quand on fait le solde he des
emplois qui qui ne seraient pas venus
dans une agglomération s'il n'y avait
pas eu la zone franche enfin moi chacun
connaît son propre exemple je suis
positif mais être positif ne veut pas
dire nier de vrais effet pervers qui
franchement existe existe toujours
aujourd'hui et font des ordres hein et
euh alors que que que par
ailleurs le but premier était aussi de
favoriser l'embauche hein de personnes
et notamment de jeunes issus des
quartiers dans lesquels ou à proximité
desquels sont situés ces nouvelles zones
économiques vous avez eu raison de le
rappeler voilà monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
euh je veux dire simplement que que le
gouvernement avec le le soutien de la
majorité a sur ces questions une vraie
sensibilité je pense qu'on n pas dans
une situation où les uns feraient la
leçon aux autres hein nous avons
là-dessus nous partageons les mêmes
valeurs républicaines nous croyons tous
que les discriminations il faut les
combattre nous pensons tous tous que
cette diversité française est une est
une force à condition de de poursuivre
le le travail et et et je pense
sincèrement que le gouvernement de la
République à travers un certain nombre
de mesures qui ont été engagées qui ont
été amplifiés qui ont été mis en œuvre a
fait dans ce
domaine un un d'ors et déjà un un chemin
important et qu'il entend bien continuer
à le faire dans l'esprit que je viens de
rappeler tout à l'heure je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre c'est la fin
de ce débat consacré à la lutte contre
les discriminations je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine à partir de mardi
16h30 pour une prochaine séance cette
fois-ci consacrée au projet de loi
relatif au Grand Paris merci de votre
fidélité à très bientôt sur Public
Sénat